Das ist 22 Uhr.
Bis dann, tschüss. Ich, Ni, San, Shi. Ich nie san chi.
Taktische Manöver, Prozessorenkunde. Während Omi sich nur noch mit Doppelherz am Schnaufen halten kann, denkt Klein-Erwin nur noch an Megahertz. Und wenn er dann seine prozessoralen Überflieger an Stromnetz kneift, wird der Schrittmacher von Omi immer flotter. War früher ein dicker Manta schon geil, ist heute ohne Schallmauer durchbrechende CPU kein Start mehr zu machen. Doch was soll man nehmen? Pentium, K6, PowerPC, Alpha oder doch noch 68K? Welcher Prozessor ist eigentlich für was geeignet und was ist eigentlich ein Embedded Prozessor? Und ist das eigentlich wichtig? Chaosradio beleuchtet die Technik jenseits der Plastikverschadung und geht auf die Suche nach dem Geist in der Maschine. Und wir prüfen, ob das Internet nicht vielleicht sogar der bessere Prozessor ist.
Und so demokratisch geht es zumindest zu, ist überhaupt keine Frage. Tim, Andreas und Hans sind von Chaos Computer Club hier. Mein Name ist mit Schwamm und wir gucken mal, ob wir das merken. Ich bin die Vertretung von Johnny.
Wie geht es ihm eigentlich?
Ich glaube es geht ihm nicht so gut immer noch. Also er braucht noch 2-3 Tage, sagt er, bis er wieder auf dem Damm ist. So richtig harte Grippe.
Aber das hat doch hoffentlich nichts mit Hühnern zu tun.
Nee, davon war nicht die Rede.
Wir überprüfen das noch. Tja, wir haben ja sogar ein Thema heute.
So ein schickes sogar. Genau. Prozessoren.
Wir haben uns was richtig Lustiges einfallen lassen, sodass es den Fritz-Moderatoren schon irgendwie ein Kloss in den Hals setzt. Nachdem wir die letzten beiden Sendungen dann doch eher lustiger und abschweifender verbracht haben, insbesondere die letzten zwei Jahresfeiern, die 23. Sendung, die hat uns eine Menge Spaß gemacht.
Und ich hoffentlich auch.
Wollen wir diesmal ein bisschen mehr mal wieder ans Eingemachte gehen. Es gibt ja da mal zwei Fraktionen bei den Mails, die wir bekommen. Die einen sagen irgendwie, redet doch nicht so viel über Computer. Und die anderen sagen halt, wieso redet ihr nicht mehr über Computer? Ihr seid doch der Chaos Computer Club. Wir haben da ja auch immer so unsere Probleme, dass wir ja eigentlich eher so als Technik, ja, liebende Gruppe angesehen werden.
Das sind wir doch auch oder nicht?
Ja, wir sind es, aber wir sind es halt so, eben auch nicht so, ach, zwei Herzen schlagen in meiner Wurst heißt es dann doch, glaube ich. Weil wenn man sich halt zu lange mit diesen Maschinen beschäftigt, dann gehen sie einem ja dann irgendwann auch ganz schön auf den Senkel. Aber sein lassen können wir es natürlich trotzdem nicht. Und es gibt ja bei allem dann auch immer noch diesen kleinen politischen Aspekt. Den lassen wir aber heute einfach mal komplett sein. Heute geht es sozusagen ums Eingemachte, heute geht es um die Pins, um die Chips, die Beschichtung, die Siliziumwege und wir wollen da mal ein bisschen reingraben, wie denn das eigentlich so ist mit diesen Computern und warum die eigentlich das tun, was sie tun.
Jetzt musst du die Frage fragen, Putz.
Im Dezember habt ihr euren wundervollen Kongress veranstaltet, wieder mal in Hamburg. Warum ist er nicht eigentlich in Berlin geblieben? Irgendwann war er doch mal kurz in Berlin.
Na ja, es hat sich zufällig eine günstige Raumsituation ergeben in Berlin vor mittlerweile drei Jahren und die gibt es jetzt halt nicht mehr. Allgemeine Trägheit hält heute den Kongress in Hamburg, wo Räumlichkeiten zur Verfügung stehen, die dieses Jahr auch schon wieder ein bisschen zu klein waren. Also es waren ungefähr doppelt so viele Leute da, wie wir reingepasst haben. Es gab diesmal, wie ich fand, sehr interessante Workshops, sehr interessante Vorträge mit sehr, sehr viel Inhalten im Vergleich zu den letzten Jahren. Und ich glaube, wir hatten alle sehr viel Spaß dabei.
Und wie war der Workshop, wo Herr Kanter nicht anwesend war? Irgendwo habe ich gelesen, Herr Kanter war eingeladen oder zumindest ein Vertreter seiner Zunft.
Das ging wahrscheinlich um den, der auch in den Medien heftig bestritten wurde aufgrund von Umstriffen.
Die Kryptodebatten.
Kryptografie war ja eines der großen Themen im letzten Jahr. Neben den EC-Karten, die uns überhaupt nicht mehr losgelassen haben. Aber es gab eigentlich eine ganze Menge auf diesem Kongress. Was sehr positiv aufgestoßen ist, dass dieses Mal auch wieder wirklich ein Leben da reingekommen ist, wie wir das seit vielen Jahren nicht mehr gehabt haben. Der Ansturm war also unglaublich groß. Außerdem waren auch die Qualität von den Vorträgen sehr hoch. Es wurden da Workshops gehalten, wie hacken ich Chipkarts, und zwar in zwei Teilen. Die erste hat die gewaltlose Variante abgedeckt. Der zweite Teil war dann die nicht ganz so gewaltlose Methode, wie man an einer Chipkarte ihre Geheimnisse entlockt. Ähnliches gab es zu GSM-Hacking, was ja auch gerade ein heißes Thema ist. Und vieles andere mehr. Wer sich die Themen interessiert, kann sich das bei uns auf dem Web-Server anschauen. Wir haben den alten Fahrplan, also unser 3-Tages-Programm, was wir im Kongress haben. Der steht noch auf dem Server, den kann man sich anschauen.
Da wird es demnächst bei presse.ccc.de auch Zusammenfassungen der Veranstaltungen geben?
Das gibt es schon lange, seitdem der Kongress zu Ende ist. presse.ccc.de ist die komplette Kongressdokumentation. Das sind absträgt, teilweise auch längere Papiere von den Vortragenden, bzw. wo nicht verfügbar, von unserer eigenen Presse-Stelle auf dem Kongress zusammengetragene Informationen. Da ist der Kongress eigentlich relativ gut abgedeckt. Also ist eine Menge Material zu finden.
Und wahrscheinlich gibt es nächstes Jahr wieder einen?
Auf jeden Fall, ja, gibt es nächstes Jahr wieder einen Kongress.
Wenn das so viel Platz und viele Leute hat, warum macht ihr das nicht zweimal im Jahr im Sommer?
Da haben wir in der Tat auch schon drüber nachgedacht.
Ich meine, es ist halt auch so eine Veranstaltung, die jetzt halt 10 Jahre läuft und wo man sich einfach so traditionell trifft, dass es schon schwierig ist, überhaupt das woanders zu machen. Wir haben das einmal geschafft, aber es klebt halt trotzdem in dieser Schule.
Das klingt aus wie eine Schwierigkeit mit Berlin. Es wird da viel darüber diskutiert. Und seitdem diese HIP gelaufen ist im Sommer letzten Jahres, also diese Sommercampingveranstaltungen, sind auch viele Leute auf den Kongress auf uns zugekommen. Ja, und man könnte ja auch mal vielleicht nicht bei minus 12 Grad und vielleicht nicht gerade, wenn man sowieso irgendwie nach Süddeutschland zu seinen Eltern fahren muss. Dafür haben wir vollstes Verständnis. Auf der anderen Seite ist natürlich dieser Termin, der immer vom 27. bis zum 29. Fest zwischen Weihnachten und Silvester eingebackt liegt, der ist halt insofern auch grandios, weil einfach kein Mensch auf die Idee kommen würde, an so einem Datum einen Kongress zu machen. Von daher war überhaupt keine Konkurrenz. Also wie man es dreht und wendet...
Na, das ist nicht richtig, wir haben doch Konkurrenz. Es gibt doch immer The Party vom 27. bis 29.12. und das große Treffen der Demo-Szene.
Na gut, es richtet sich nicht unbedingt an den gleichen guten Kreis. Ach, die Demo-Szene, Entschuldigung, hab ich jetzt einen falschen Hals gekriegt.
Aber wir denken in der Tat ernsthaft drüber nach, vielleicht auch im Sommer was zu machen. Das wird dieses Jahr garantiert nichts mehr, wegen der fehlenden Vorlaufzeit. Möglicherweise nächstes Jahr, wenn wir uns aufraffen können. Sicherlich wird das unter einem anderen Aspekt als die Winterveranstaltungen stehen. Also mehr Spaß haben, ausprobieren und zelten mit Ethernetz sowie auf der HIP. Und dann wieder im Winter eher die ernsthaften, interessanten, schwierigen Themen.
Genau, aber das ist einfach viel Arbeit. Man hat auch bei der HIP gesehen, so toll das alles war. Da müssen sehr viele Leute in einem Strang ziehen. Dass sich das Ganze auch noch rechnet, ist auch noch ein Problem für sich. Aber das ist ja nicht der Kernpunkt. Wir würden das schon gerne machen, aber wir haben jetzt erstmal einen anderen Fokus. Das nächste Mal sind wir auf der CeBIT. Das ist schon fest.
Auf der richtigen.
Auf der richtigen, echten, realen CeBIT.
Und das ist vom 19. bis zum 25. März ist das diesmal wieder. Und wir sind im Stand vertreten in Halle 22, wenn ich das richtig noch im Kopf habe. Und das war letztes Jahr schon ganz nett. Und wir sind wieder am gleichen Ort. Also wer da schon mal war, weiß wo es ist. Und wer nicht, der wird es dann auch bald auf dem Web-Server finden. www.ccc.de, ihr wisst ja. Jetzt können wir noch ein bisschen von der köstlichen Musik rein.
Erzählst du kurz was über die Musik? Wer die gemacht hat?
Also das ist sozusagen, ich muss ja auch natürlich ein bisschen lauter machen. Hört man ja gar nichts. Oder ist das nur bei mir so leise? Also dieses wunderbare prozessorale Gezirpe da hinten, das ist die Prozessor-Musik von Silicon und Sapphire, SOS. Eine Gruppe von DJs, die das für diese Sendung extra zusammengestellt hat. Wir hatten das letzte Sendung ja schon. Und wir wollen das auch dieses Jahr beibehalten, dass wir mehr gute Musik haben. Wir nennen das Ganze Mars-Musik. Und wenn wir letztlich dieses Jahr noch gute Beispiele präsentieren können.
Ich möchte mal gleich wegschweben, nicht auf die irrischen Selizium-Teile runterkommen.
Ich denke auch sehr nach Prozessor, also wenn man mal ein Radio neben einem offenen PC stellt, klingt es manchmal ähnlich.
War das jetzt ein Kompliment?
Äh, weiß ich nicht.
Für den PC.
Angeblich gab es früher sogar mal ein Spiel, bei dem das Absicht war, wo man tatsächlich ein Radio daneben stellen sollte, auf einen kleinen Kanal drehen sollte, und dann waren die Instruktionen so geteilt, dass sich die Musik zu dem Spiel im Radio wieder fand, weil der Computer damals noch nicht über einen Sound-Ausgabe verfügte.
Er leitet mich so ein bisschen an diese Festplatten- und Diskettenlaufwerksmusik, die wir damals irgendwie auf dem C64 hatten. Da konnte man im Prozessor auch schon lustige Sachen machen. Kennt ihr das noch? Das kleine Diskettenlaufwerkselied vom C64? Wo der Kopf von dem Diskettenlaufwerk immer nach hinten gefeuert wurde, und gegen den Anschlag donnerte, wo er sich immer selbst kalibriert hatte, und irgendwann ist er auf die Idee gekommen, ein kleines Liedchen zu singen. Fast so gut wie alle meine Eltern auf der Telefon-Tastatur.
Heute geht es um Computer, ne?
Wir wollen ja jetzt auch was erzählen, ne?
Naja, also wir haben hier irgendwie zwei Computer-Freaks und einen, noch einen Computer-Freak und einen Moderator.
Hans, du hast auch immer den Durchblick, was die Vergangenheit betrifft.
Du bist auch so ein Ewig-Gestriger.
Das liegt einem im Alter. Wie war denn das mit den Lochkarten?
Früher gab es doch keine Prozessoren.
Ja, stimmt. Ich meine, wir können ja mal einfach so einsteigen, wie wir das besprochen haben. In den 70er Jahren begab es sich, dass man, wie oft die Idee kam, mehrere Transistorfunktionen auf einen Chip tun konnte.
Müssen wir jetzt erklären, was ein Transistor ist?
Nein, das müssen wir nicht erklären. Das hatte den unerhörigen Vorteil, dass bis dahin Computer immer raumfühlende Maschinen waren. Durch diese Integration wurde es plötzlich möglich, diese raumfühlenden Maschinen in kleine handliche Geräte einzubauen. Die Weltfirma Intel war schon damals voll dabei.
Von welchem Zeitraum reden wir denn jetzt?
Wir reden jetzt von Anfang der 70er Jahre, also die genaue Zeithalle haben wir uns jetzt mal geschenkt. Ich glaube, das Patent ist von 1969 oder so was. Anfang der 70er Jahre kam dann der erste Prozessor von der Firma Intel auf den Markt. Das war der Prozessor 4004, der nach heutigen Maßstäben zwar sehr simpel aussieht, aber im Prinzip genauso funktioniert wie die Computer heute.
Es handelte sich, glaube ich, um einen 4-Bit Prozessor mit 2300 Transistorfunktionen.
Ja, aber die Leistungsfähigkeit war immens, weil es war, wie gesagt, damals, so lässt man noch zu dieser Zeit, naja, hören vielleicht nicht mehr, aber man hatte einzelne Transistoren, die man auf große Platinen löten musste und 2300 Transistoren auf Platinen ist einfach schon mal ein kleiner Schrank.
Die Presseerklärung lautet dann auch Computer on a Chip.
Schade, die ist super, weil die ist deswegen super, weil man würde das also mit kleinen Abstrichen auch heute noch genauso vertragen, diesen Marketing-Blah irgendwie Impressive Power und all that you want. Ja, und Intel hat dann halt weitergemacht und hat diese Prozessoren eben auch entscheidend mit weiterentwickelt. Also es ging dann über diese Vierer, also mit den Vierbit hat man dann schnell festgestellt, dass das eigentlich nichts taugt, weil das irgendwie doch ein bisschen wenig ist von der Wortbreite. Und daraufhin hat man sich dann zumindest auf Bytes, also auf 8-Bit geeinigt.
Das hat aber eine Weile gedauert, bis sie sich auf 8-Bit geeinigt haben.
Das muss man aber Intel zugute halten. Also mit dem 4004 und dem darauf folgenden 8008 war das eigentlich abgefeiert. Dabei war die Beidweite für den Konsum am Markt einfach gesetzt. Du meinst, Intel setzt die Standards, ja? Ja, ist der Fall. Bis Ende der 60er Jahre gab es durchaus noch Maschinen, die also 12-Bit Wortbreite hatten. Und 36-Bit die großen Rechner und dann hat man auch nochmal hier so ein Witz spendiert, um irgendwie Protection oder irgendwas zu machen oder so. Aber das war dann völlig out, dann musste es irgendwie streamlinen, we have these bytes.
C-Programmierer sehen das ja heute noch, dass es irgendwie auch mal einen 9-Bit Computer gab. Ich erinnere an die Oktal-Schreibweise, die ja irgendwie für 8-Bit wenig Sinn macht, aber irgendwie für einen 9-Bit Computer echt prima angemessen war.
Ja, aber inzwischen ist das echt fast völlig verdrängt. Ich meine, im Unix haben wir so ein bisschen die Oktal-Zahlen noch deswegen, weil das eben gerade so, dieses System gerade so aus der Kippe kommt, wo es sich dann auf diese reinen 8-Bit breiten Bits konzentriert hat. Ansonsten hat ja niemand mehr irgendwas anderes als 8-Bit.
Und was ist dann passiert? Und wer war eigentlich für Neumann?
Neumann? Neumann war der, der sich ausgedacht hat, dass man gefälliges Programm und Daten gleich behandeln sollte, also in den gleichen Speicher tun sollte, was natürlich den deutlichen Vorteil hatte. Wenn man seine Programme wie Daten behandeln konnte, konnte man erst zu Sachen wie Compiler schreiben oder überhaupt Assembler, konnte überhaupt erst die ersten Betriebssysteme schreiben usw. Also die Architektur, dass Datenprogramme gleich behandelt werden, die bezeichnet als von Neumann Architektur und das teilen sich eigentlich alle modernen Computersysteme.
Die sogenannten PCs, ja.
Ich meine, welcher Computer ist denn sozusagen nicht nach der von Neumann Architektur gebaut?
Fängt mir spontan keiner ein, aber ich glaube der Z3, wo dann auf der einen Seite ein Lochstreifen reinging, wo das Programm drauf war, und auf der anderen Seite gab es eine größere Anzahl Relais, wo dann die Daten drin steckten, das war glaube ich keine von Neumann Architektur.
Also das ist schon die prinzipielle Architektur. Ja, alles klar von normalen Standards.
Irak-Konflikt. US-Außenministerin Albright will in der Nacht nach Europa fliegen, um in Paris, Moskau und London für eine harte Linie zu werben. Albright droht am Abend erneut mit einem militärischen Schlag gegen den Irak, falls die UNO-Waffeninspekteure nicht ungehinderten Zugang zu allen Einrichtungen bekämen. Baufelsaffäre. Der unter Korruptionsverdacht stehende Potsdamer Baustadt Radkaminski muss seinen Posten räumen. Das Stadtparlament stimmte mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit für die Amtsenthebung. Dem SPD-Politiker wird Vorteilsnahme im Amt vorgeworfen. EU-Strafe. Der VW-Konzern muss wegen unzulässiger Verkaufspraktiken eine Geldbuse von über 200 Millionen Mark bezahlen. Die EU-Kommission sieht es als erwiesen an, dass VW den Händlern in Italien einen Verkauf seiner Autos an deutschen Kunden untersagt hat. Der Wolfsburger Konzern will die Geldstrafe nicht akzeptieren und kündigte eine Klage beim Europäischen Gerichtshof an. Nordirland-Konflikt. Ohne Ergebnis ist heute in London eine weitere Verhandlungsrunde über die Zukunft der Provinz beendet worden. Allerdings gebe es eine erste Annäherung, hieß es. Kernpunkt der Gespräche ist eine britisch-irische Friedensinitiative. Am Montag wird in Belfast weiter verhandelt. Skifahren. Martina Ertl hat wenige Tage vor Beginn der Olympischen Winterspiele den ersten Nachtriesensladum im schwedischen Arl gewonnen. Zweite wurde die Schweizerin Sonja Neff den dritten Platz belegte, die Schwedin Anna Ottersson. Nachts aufgelockerte Bewölkung minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad. Achtung, Glätte am Tag niederschlagsfrei minus 1 bis 3 Grad. Berlin-Welmersdorf. Die Brandenburgische Straße ist zwischen Mannheimer und Berliner Straße wegen eines Feuerwehreinsatzes in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. A111 Stadtautobahn Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg. Der Tunnel Tegel-Ortskern ist gesperrt. Eine Umleitung ist ausgewiesen. Und Brandenburg-Potztamm im gesamten Bereich Glättebildung durch überfrierende Nässe, insbesondere auf Bundesautobahnen und Bundesstraßen, stellenweise sichtweiten unter 50 Metern. Fahrt bitte vorsichtig.
Das war ein kurzes Fritz-Info mit Carsten Koch.
Das ist jetzt aber Alba.
Es muss nicht immer Europa-Liga sein.
Alba Berlin gegen USC Freiburg.
Sonntag, 1.
Februar, 15 Uhr in der Mark-Schmeling-Halle.
Auch Bundesliga macht Spaß. Alba Berlin gegen USC Freiburg.
Und nicht vergessen, wenn Alba, dann Fritz.
Wie sich das gehört mit dem Chaos Computer Club, heute mit Andreas, Hans und Tim. Tim winkt immer. Ah, wundervolle Musik. Ich hab vorhin schon vorgeschlagen, die ganzen Zahlen, die in der Sendung auftauchen, am Ende mal zusammenzurechnen. Ich hab allerdings nicht buchgeführt, also wir lassen das lieber.
Vielleicht können wir das ja in unserer Hörer weitergeben.
Es ging jedenfalls reichlich um Bits und all diese Geschichten. Wie kann man sich denn das vorstellen? Also warum funktioniert so ein Prozessor? Also warum die funktionieren?
Also es hat viel mit Silizium zu tun, richtig.
Also warum ist eine komplizierte Frage, aber vielleicht können wir erstmal drauf eingehen, was sie machen. Und zwar, was ein Prozessor im Wesentlichen auszeichnet, ist, dass er die Möglichkeit hat, auf Speicher zuzugreifen und sich aus dem Speicher den nächsten Programmschritt holt und diesen Programmschritt ausführt. Und das Ausführen des Programmschritts hat meistens damit zu tun, Daten aus dem Speicher zu holen, diese zu verarbeiten, also meistens zu addieren und zu multiplizieren und an einer anderen Stelle wieder abzulegen.
Na ja, und das, was ihnen dann wirklich interessant macht, ist die Fähigkeit, das nach außen zu kommunizieren. Das heißt, man kann irgendwelche Leitungen ansteuern, irgendwelche Bildschirmpunkte oder irgendwelche Tastaturen abfragen.
Grafische Benutzerschnittstellen.
Das ermöglicht ihm dann, dem Prozessor seine Ergebnisse zu kommunizieren.
Genau, es wird ja immer ein Höllenbombo-Jum gemacht um Prozessoren heutzutage. Man muss ja erstmal den schnellsten haben, und man muss irgendwie vielleicht sogar noch mehr als einen haben. Und man sollte natürlich auch immer den neuesten haben. Wir werden so auf so ein paar irrsinnige Konzepte, die da in der Marketingmaschine immer so gefeiert werden, werden wir sicherlich noch mal ein bisschen eingehen. Es sind ja nur MMX und ähnliche, ich glaube. Aber Prozessoren haben auf jeden Fall diese Welt mindestens noch mal genauso verändert, wie das der Transistor vorher schon getan hat, der diese Maschine eigentlich im Prinzip überhaupt erst ermöglicht hat. Aber der Prozessor und der Computer und der Chip hat diese Leistungsfähigkeit des Programmarbeitens natürlich enorm nach vorne getrieben.
Aber eigentlich ist von Prozessor nichts anderes als eine große Menge von Transistoren. Oder sind da schon noch ein paar andere...
Da sind ja sowieso die meisten Chips im Computer.
Im Wesentlichen sind es schon Transistoren. Wobei mit der großen Menge das natürlich auch relativ zu betrachten ist, weil die Basisfunktionenität des 4004 mit 2300 Transistoren ist im Prinzip vergleichbar mit den Chips, die wir heute haben, mit den Prozessoren, die Millionen von Transistoren haben. Also was da eine große Zahl ist, ist da noch...
Wir können ja noch ein paar Eckdaten nennen. Also der 68000 heißt zum Beispiel 68000, weil er 68000 Transistoren hat. Und mittlerweile liegen wir bei den großen CPUs im Bereich von 5 bis 6 Millionen Transistoren.
Was nicht unbedingt gut sein muss, weil wie viel ist da nicht unbedingt mehr. Viel Transistoren machen auch viel heiß.
Und viel Transistoren kosten Fläche. Und interessanterweise wächst der Preis eines Chips kubisch mit der Fläche. Das heißt, ein Chip, der doppelt so groß ist, kostet achtmal so viel. Das hat den ganz einfachen Grund, dass es eine bestimmte Häufigkeit von Verschmutzung gibt auf einem Wafer. Zum Wafer sind diese Lützungscheiben, auf denen die Chips hergestellt werden. Und wenn da viele kleine drauf sind, man hat zehn Fehler, dann hat man von 80 Chips zum Beispiel zehn kaputte, bleiben 70 übrig. Wenn man aber große Chips hat, dann passen halt bloß 20 Chips drauf. Das heißt, bei zehn Fehlern sind zehn von den 20 Chips einfach im Eimer. Deswegen, je mehr Transistoren es sind, desto teurer wird das, desto heißer wird das alles und so weiter und so fort.
Und interessanterweise wird mit dieser gewaltigen Anzahl von Transistoren heute hauptsächlich das gemacht, nämlich eine einzige 4004++ noch schneller zu gestalten. Das kann man zu unserem Kerl immer dem Intel verschenken. Es ist ja inzwischen, muss man ja zugeben, dass auch andere Einflüsse doch...
Meinst du auch, andere Prozessoren sind schlecht?
Nein, aber auch andere, ja gut, okay. Aber man könnte zum Beispiel auf einem Chip ja 100 Prozessoren machen, wäre prinzipiell möglich.
Das ist übrigens tatsächlich das, was Motorola mit der G4-Geschichte, glaube ich, in plant. Also da ist leider nicht so sehr viel bekannt, aber eine Idee ist sozusagen die Paralysierung dadurch voranzutreiben, dass man eben gleich mehrere Prozessoren eben auf einen Chip packt. Also Multi-Prozessor heißt dann noch nicht mal unbedingt mehr Multi-Chip.
Aber das ist natürlich immer schwierig, weil man dann halt auch bloß einmal die I.O.-Bandbreite für alle Chips hat und so weiter. Von Texas Instruments gibt es das zum Beispiel, gibt es den TMS 320C60, der viermal den TMS 320C50 enthält. Das sind sehr obskure Prozessoren mit einigen sehr obskuren Befehlen. Zum Beispiel gibt es da eine Adressierungsart, wo die Low-Order-Bits der Adresse vertauscht werden. Also man kann sagen, die untersten sechs oder die untersten acht Bits werden gedreht. Die Bits, die vorne waren, nach hinten, die hinten nach vorne. Und das Ganze beschleunigt die Fast-Foyer-Transformation. Braucht man also eigentlich außer für die Fast-Foyer-Transformation gar nicht. Aber das ist nur mal das, was die SPs 80% ihrer Zeit machen.
Fast-Foyer-Transformation doch, das ist interessant. Ich bin eigentlich genau der Falsche als der Erklärer, aber ich brauche erstmal trotzdem, mal gucken, wie viele Minuspunkte ich kriege. Fast-Foyer-Transformation ist eine mathematische Methode, schnell Frequenzanteile aus einem Signal herauszufiltern, also zu bestimmen, wie stark hier einzelne Frequenzen darin enthalten sind. Die Basis für viele Erkennungsmethoden, wie auch Spracherkennung zum Beispiel, oder irgendwie diese DTMF-Erkennung, dass man in der Lage ist, einen Anrufsbeantworter abzufragen, da muss halt auch irgendwie das Signal, was da kommt, also das, was man hört, analysiert werden. Welche Frequenzen da drin sind? Wenn ich auf einer Telefon-Tastatur so eine Taste drücke, dann wird ja immer eine Kombination aus zwei Tönen gespielt. Das ist eine 4x4-Matrix, und es gibt halt 16 verschiedene Kombinationen, so 4x4 verschiedene Frequenzen. Und FFT, also die Fast Fourier Transformation, ist so der typische Weg, wie man sowas erkennt.
Also mit den heutigen Prozessoren könnte man aber auch mit einer sehr naiven Fourier Transformation, da braucht man keine Fast Fourier Transformation, könnte man DTMF-Töne erkennen.
Gut, jetzt kriege ich meine Niederspunkte.
Aber sehr wichtig ist das tatsächlich zum Zerlegen von natürlichen, nicht diskreten Signalen in diskrete Einheiten, mit denen man mit einem Computer, mit einem digitalen System auch was anfangen kann. Zum Beispiel ein Bild erkennen oder Sprache erkennen.
Premiere damit gucken.
Premiere damit gucken, genau.
Interessanter Punkt. D-Box ist ja auch ein schönes Thema im Kongress gewesen. Zur Erklärung, der Chaos Computer Club verkauft keine D-Box-Bauanleitung. Es gibt da draußen gerade viele Leute, die das glauben. Vor der Datenschleuder haben wir einen Bauplan gezeigt, wie man da andere Vorteile daraus ziehen kann, wenn man eine D-Box bereits hat.
Konkret ist es so, dass in der D-Box ein 68.340 drin steckt. Ein derivatives 68.000 für den Embedded-Einsatz. Diese CPU verfügt über einen Debugging-Port. Was in der Datenschule da war, war eine Bauanleitung für ein Interface, damit man diesen Debugging-Port an seinen PC anschließen kann. Dann mithilfe einer Software, die bei uns auf dem Web-Server liegt, das EEPROM updaten kann, dass eine D-Box drin steckt. Das Problem bei der D-Box ist nämlich, dass normalerweise Leo Kirch bei sich auf den Knopf drückt. Dann bekommt man in seine D-Box eine neue Software eingespielt und kann bloß noch das gucken, was Leo Kirch gerne möchte. Deshalb ist das für uns die Konkurrenzsoftware, mit der man auch die anderen Kanäle noch gucken kann.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mit dem Embedded-Prozessor noch mal vertiefen, weil ein Debug-Pod und...
Gleich, vielleicht noch mal kurz für die Leute, die mir gerade klar geworden sind, dass vielleicht nicht unbedingt jeder weiß, was eine D-Box ist.
Also D-Box ist ein Produkt, was in Deutschland bis vor kurzem noch kort nicht erhältlich war.
Das ist irgendwie von der, ich glaube, von der EG...
Moment mal, das gibt es immer noch. Es gibt es bloß nicht zum Premiere-Gucken. Also es gibt es nach wie vor zum DF1-Gucken.
Ach so, alles klar.
Und im Wort Debug ist auch das Wort Debug fast mit drin.
Ja, es lädt geradezu dazu ein. Also Debug sozusagen das, was einem digitales Fernsehen auch seinen alten Fernseher zaubert und damit die Halbwertszeit dieser Maschine nicht ganz so gering ist, wie sie von Haus aus ist. Dafür gibt es dann halt die Datenschleuder. Aber wir verkaufen keine Debug-Bauerleitungen. Jetzt kannst du ja nochmal erklären, was ein Embedded-Prozessor ist.
Ja, das ist wirklich interessant, weil das ist an sich ein interessanter Ansatz. Und zwar ist ein Embedded-Prozessor ein Prozessor, der für den Einsatz in Nicht-Computern ausgelegt ist. Also der jetzt nicht dafür da ist, irgendeine Universale... Ja, gut, das war jetzt die Stelle.
Also der ist nicht...
Ja, nur zur Erklärung.
Wollen wir das jetzt weiter vertiefen? Ja, vertiefen wir das jetzt. Der nicht für den Einsatz in einem Computer gemacht ist, sondern für den Einsatz in einem Kühlschrank. Oder eben in einem Bleistift. Ja, und das interessante an diesen Debug-Ports ist, dass so ein Embedded-Prozessor immer neben dem eigentlichen Prozessor auch noch andere Komponenten hat, zum Beispiel eine Schnittstelle, um Grafik auf dem Bildschirm zu zaubern oder eine Schnittstelle, um mit dem Telefonnetz zu reden oder alles Mögliche. Das ist natürlich dann etwas schwierig mit so einem Chip umzugehen, weil das ist ja irgendwie eine kleine Einheit und man kommt da von außen nicht dran. Und wenn das Ding läuft, dann läuft das und man kommt da eben nicht dran. Deswegen gibt es den Debug-Port, mit dem man auch von außen direkt intern eingreifen kann, weil man ansonsten die Wartungsschnittstelle. Das, was wir bei den Telefonanlagen immer gesucht haben, bei den Embedded-Prozessoren ist das standardfreundlicherweise bei der Firma Motorola, nach einem auch standardisierten und dokumentierten Verfahren von Motorola, sodass man Debug-Ports sehr leicht benutzen kann und z.B. auch die Motorola-Telefone.
Das also als beliebte PT9 verfügt über dasselbe Interface.
Genau, die alle diese Embedded-Debug-Schnittstelle haben.
Das PT9 ist die E-Netz-Geschichte, ne? Die E-Netz-Variante.
Mikrotext, 8000.
Ja, ja.
Völlig braune Telefone. Wobei ich dann nur eine interessante Frage habe. Und zwar, was macht ein Computer aus? Diese D-Box hat immerhin die Möglichkeit, Text auf den Bildschirm auszugeben. Sie hat einen SCSI-Port, einen Modem, einen MPEG-2-Decoder, einen Infrarotsender. Hab ich was vergessen.
Die Programmierbarkeit macht den Computer aus.
Na gut, dann verwandelt sozusagen das BDM-Interface, die Setup-Box in einen Computer.
So sieht's aus. Eigentlich ist das ein ganz schicker Computer, weil der immerhin die genannten Schnittstellen besitzt.
Vielleicht sollte man versuchen, Linux draufzubooten.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist TOS oder sowas leichter zu portieren.
Und mein Linux 68K gibt's auch schon.
Chaosradio bei Fritz Gander auf dem Chat fragt, welche Software zum kostenlosen Einloggen in T-Online auf dem Chaos Computer Club Server lief.
Gängiges Missverständnis. Ach, den haben wir nicht. Es befindet sich da eine T-Online Hack.zip Datei, die uns so zugespielt wurde und von der wir dachten, das wäre mal nicht schlecht, wenn wir die irgendwie auf den Server packen. Das macht nichts anderes, als die Konfigurationsdateien von dieser Windows-T-Online-Zugangssoftware zu durchforsten und einfach mal das Passwort und die Kennung, die da abgespeichert ist, im Klartext anzuzeigen. Anderen Worten, das Ding macht nichts Schlimmes, aber es zeigt was Schlimmes auf.
Also genau genommen, man darf halt seine Passwörter nicht in der Software absichtlich abspeichern.
Also es weist einfach mal wieder darauf hin, was wir schon immer sagen, Passwörter sind keine Lösungen und man soll sich nicht langsam mal was besseres einfallen lassen, als Passwörter, als nur Passwörter zu nennen. Aber wir wollen ja eigentlich über Prozessoren reden, nicht über Software.
Was hast du denn für Prozessoren in deinem Besitz?
Jetzt gerade dabei?
Naja, oder im Besitz?
Im Besitz, muss ich mal nachdenken. Also ich glaube, ich habe, da muss man Andreas nochmal helfen. Was ist in meiner kleinen Maschine, die wir alle haben? 168...
328.
168.328.
Also ein Embedded Motorola.
Genau.
Genau. Dann habe ich, ich hab derzeit ganz schön wenig, muss ich feststellen. Irgendwo in seinen Räumen fliegt noch eine 386er CPU von mir rum, von der ich mittlerweile nicht mehr genau weiß, wo sie sich befindet. Dann habe ich ein PowerPC 603. Das muss ich schon mal ein bisschen nachdenken. Ich hab noch ein 68.030 bei mir zu Hause stehen. Früher hatte ich ein 68.030, ein 68.000, ein 65.02 und...
Mit Z80 hattest du bestimmt auch schon mal mehrfach.
Nee.
Ja, doch, in deinen Tastaturen kannst du davon ausgehen.
Echt? In deinen PC-Tastaturen sind Z80 drin?
Ja, das ist immer so, wenn man den Prozessor auf Choice in der Tastatur hat.
Z80, Prozessor auf Choice, kommen wir noch zu. Aber ich hatte zumindest keinen Desktop-Computer, wenn man das überhaupt so nennen kann, oder auch keinen Home-Computer mit Z80-Basis. Ja, immer mehr in dem Bereich mit der 6 vorne.
Ja, 65.10, so einer bist du.
Na ja, doch, mit dem ZX81 hab ich auch mal ein bisschen rumgespielt, war aber nicht meiner. Und jetzt fangen wir erstmal an, keine Prozessoren, die ich habe. Aber was hast du denn?
Oh, im Moment hab ich glaub ich auch fast nur Intel-CPUs. Zum Beispiel, mein Telefon dürfte wohl ein Intel-Dirigatum sein.
Da wär ich mir nicht sicher. Mein Telefon. Auch siebenstlich eigene Mikro-Controller.
Ja, aber die sind Intel-basiert. Also X86.
Stimmt, die bauen ja auch Intel-CPUs in ihre Vermittlungsstellen an.
Ja, das ist Standard. Das hat sich leider in Deutschland auch ganz durchgesetzt. Zuhause hab ich halt diverse Pentiums. Zwei, genau. Ne, ein Pentium und einen AMD hab ich. Einen sehr schönen AMD. Der 86er.
Den AMD nimmst du, wenn du immer was berechnen musst.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, da läuft mein Geniex drauf. Sonst hab ich keine CPU, glaub ich.
Also ich habe einen PowerPC 604 und diverse 486er laufender als Router. Naja, und dann den 68328 in meiner Tasche. Eigentlich hatte ich schon immer Intel. Also ich muss mich mal outen. Ich hab mit einem XT meine Computer-Karriere angefangen. XT, da war ich aber echt privilegiert. Das war nämlich noch zu Ostzeiten.
8088.
Das war eine echt aulige CPU damals schon. Auch nach damaligem Anstieg war die richtig schlecht. Weil das war nämlich die kastierte 8086. Wenn man überhaupt so Dinge haben wollte, dann doch bitte schön die vollständige.
Aber früher hab ich auch mal am KC gesessen, einmal die gesamte Serie durch. Und da steckte ein U880 drin. Das war angeblich ein Nachbau. In Wirklichkeit war es ein Klon. Das war nämlich ein Z80, der auch über dieselben undurigentierten Befehle verfügte. Und daran sieht man also deutlich, dass es sich wohl um dieselbe Maske gehandelt hat wie beim Original Z80.
Wie habt ihr denn das geklonen?
Na ja, die haben erstmal die Chips freigelegt, dann fotografiert, dann eine Schicht abgeschliffen, dann wieder fotografiert, dann eine Schicht abgeschliffen und so weiter bis sie unten waren. Dann haben sie davon Masken gemacht. Das haben sie übrigens auch mit dem Megabit-Chip gemacht.
Wie dicht muss man das abschleifen?
Na ja, also in der Praxis wird man es wahrscheinlich eher abätzen, aber das bewegt sich so um Mikrometermaßstab.
Das ist schon feinmechanische Technologie, die schon länger bekannt ist. Also die ist länger bekannt als das Produzieren von solchen Masken.
Die Maske wird dann aber fototechnisch abgenommen?
Ja, das wird fotografiert und dann wird das wahrscheinlich analog auf ein riesiges Stück Papier übertragen und von Hand eine Maske drauf gemacht, die dann wieder auf Mikrofilm runterkopiert wird. Ein Mikrochip wird in Edz-Technik hergestellt, ähnlich wie Leiterplatten. Das heißt, da kommt ein Fotolack drauf, der wird belichtet, dann wird das Unbelichtete weggespült, dann wird es geedzt und dann wird es dotiert und dann kommt wieder eine Schicht drauf und so weiter, bis sie fertig sind.
Jetzt fragt keiner nach der Shareware, mit der man das machen kann.
Wir haben übrigens den Fritz-Web-Chat offen.
Vielleicht sollten wir das mal erwähnen.
Einige Leute scheinen das immer schon zu wissen. Auf dem Fritz-Web-Server ist ein im Web-System integrierter Chat und den liest er uns hier auch mit. Falls ihr eine Frage habt, dann könnt ihr das da reintippen. Wenn ihr keine Lust habt, Internet zu benutzen, weil das auch ganz schön sinnlos ist, könnt ihr uns auch anrufen in dieser Sendung. Du weißt bestimmt die Telefonnummer aus, wenn ich losfahre. Nein, ich weiß die nicht aus.
Es gibt die Null.
Die Fritz-Hotline ist geschaltet.
0331 für Potsdam.
7097110.
Ui, eine neue Nummer.
Der Provider hat gewechselt. Schon länger.
Wo seid ihr jetzt?
Jetzt sind wir bei den Wieler-Kollegen.
Wer sind die Wieler-Kollegen?
Wer ist denn dieser Akku?
Bei der Tee?
Wieso, wo war der denn vorher? Stimmt, das gab er in den örtlichen...
Da würde ich redlich öffentlich genochen. Das ist euer richtiges Telefonnetz.
Bei den Erwachsenen.
Jetzt kann man auch über den Hof telefonieren.
Dann kriegt er jetzt auch richtig Internet, hab ich gehört.
Zum Beispiel ist da was dran. Kannst du da irgendwas ausklautern?
Nein.
Alles ganz sicher hier.
Das bringt uns ja mal auf den Punkt, dass wir vielleicht mal beleuchten sollten, was eigentlich aktuell ist bei den Prozessoren. Wenn man sich heute irgendwie immer darüber nachdenkt, einen Computer zu kaufen, das zeigen ja auch immer wieder Untersuchungen bei den Leuten, dann denkt ja eigentlich überhaupt gar kein Mensch darüber nach, was da für ein Betriebssystem drauf ist. Also die meisten Leute gehen ja sowieso davon aus, dass da irgendwie Windows drauf ist, wenn sie den Namen überhaupt kennen. Das sind also dann doch weniger, als man vielleicht glauben mag. Aber es gibt ja auch noch andere Computer zu kaufen. Und, ähm, machen wir mal eine Liste, also neben der ganzen Intel-Familie, die wir sicherlich noch ausreichend beleuchten werden, weil dann wollen wir ja noch drauf rumhacken, gibt es immer noch irgendwie die McIntosh-Garnitur, die, ähm, den PowerPC-Chip in sich trägt, beziehungsweise die PowerPC-Familie, derzeit auf dem Markt vertreten mit dem 603-Prozessor, für vor allem tragbare und billige Geräte, und dem 604-PowerPC, für die etwa schnelleren, dickeren Maschinen und Workstations. Davon ist dann manchmal auch mehr als einer drin. Im Intel-Bereich wird nicht mehr alles verkauft, aber ist natürlich alles noch irgendwie vertreten, also nach irgendwie 80, 88, 80, na das ging ja viel früher los, also nach der 4004 kam die 8008.
Also auf den zu Intel. Das Zitat hast du bestimmt bekommen. Also bei den Intel-CPUs ist es ja deswegen so ein Kreuz, weil sich diese Geschichte seit den 70er Jahren eben kontinuierlich entwickelt hat, und jeweils die nächste Prozessor-Generation von Intel auch die gleichen Programme verstehen musste wie die vorherige Generation. Während in den 70er Jahren also das Design von Prozessoren noch wesentlich davon getrieben war, wie viele Transistoren man nun auf seinen Schiff unterkriegte, und das waren dann halt so, ob es jetzt 5000 oder 6000 sind, sind die Maßstäbe und die Vorgaben, die man hat heute natürlich andere. Und Intel leidet halt darunter, dass sie immer diesen Ballast aus den frühen 70er Jahren mitschleppen müssten. Es gibt da ein schönes Zitat von dem...
Mike Johnson, der ist Leader des 80 x86 Designteams bei AMD. Der meinte, the x86 isn't all that complex. It just doesn't make a lot of sense.
Was so viel heißt, wie dieser Befehlssatz ist, Unsinn.
Genau, der passiert nämlich... Also im Grunde genommen kann man ihn direkt auf die 4004 CPU zurückverfolgen. Da kamen nicht die 8008, dann später die 8080 und dann als die 8086 kam, die Architektur, die also nach wie vor zu den heutigen CPUs von Intel binär-kompatibel ist, die war assembler-kompatibel. Also da konnte man die selben Assembler-Programme wie für den 8080 drauf laufen lassen. Na ja, wir haben jetzt heute 32-bit-CPUs, die im Wesentlichen zu 8-bit-CPUs binär-kompatibel sind, und deshalb eine Menge Schrott mit sich herumschleppen.
Genau, im Prinzip ist ein Pentium eine komplette Müllhalde von 20 Jahren irgendwie vergeblich ein Versuch, uns gute Prozessoren zu bauen, alles aufeinander getürmt, und hier und da schrauben sie dann nochmal bestimmte Booster und Turbo und irgendwie Fächerkrümmer ein, damit die Maschine überhaupt noch ein bisschen schneller läuft.
Ja, Intel leitet...
Bommel fragt im Chat, was der Unterschied zwischen den Firmen ist, AMD, Zürichs und Intel, also was die Prozessoren unterscheiden. Ist denn da über... also ich vermute mal, dass AMD genau die selbe Architektur mit sich herumschleppt wie Intel, oder gibt es da prinzipielle Unterschiede?
Es gibt da schon prinzipielle Unterschiede. Also jetzt gemessen natürlich am 4004 leihen die sich natürlich ihre Prinzipielles Funktionieren. Alle bei diesem Memory, IO. Computing Unit, Alu, da leihen die sich schon alle das aus. Aber es gibt schon unterschiedliche Strategien, mit diesen alten Befehlssätzen fertig zu werden, weil inzwischen gibt es halt, also der State of the Art, wenn man heute eine CPU macht, da baut man den Befehlssatz ganz anders auf, den baut man so auf, dass man bei den heutigen Taktraten und bei der heutigen Anordnung von den einzelnen Komponenten der CPU auch optimalen Durchsatz kriegt. Und es gibt jetzt halt Rangehensweisen, dass man die Intel Instruktion in der CPU in solche RISC Instruktionen umwandelt, das macht AMD zum Beispiel. Die haben insbesondere jetzt seit der Next-Gen gekauft, haben sie eine CPU, die eben ganz genau so funktioniert. Die nimmt die Intel Instruktion, baut die um zu RISC Instruktionen und füttert die in einen richtigen normalen, also nach heutigen Standard normalen RISC Kern rein.
Das ist ungefähr so, als würde man Diesel tanken und intern einen Umsetzern nach Kerosin einsbauen, damit der das so schnell laufen kann.
Aber leider bringt das so wenig durch, als dass genug Kerosin kommt.
Ja, und Intel ist zum Beispiel ein Vertreter von CPU-Bauern, die das CPU-Design noch an diesen Instruktionssatz dran haben. Die haben also eine ganz originäre Strategie, diesen originalen Instruktionssatz in ihre Hardware reinzukriegen. Natürlich auch mit jeder Menge Anleihen, ein heutiges Prozessordesign. Und die bauen ja auch schnelle CPUs, so ist es ja nicht, aber das ist halt ziemlich hanebüchen, wie das da intern teilweise aussieht, weil man irgendwie... Man hat es ja gesehen, als Intel mit großem Hello den Pentium Pro angekündigt hat. Da haben sich dann diese ganzen Windows-User auf diesen neuen Prozessor gestürzt und ihre 16-Bit-Applikationen darauf abgefahren. Und das ist einfach langsam gewesen, weil der Pentium Pro nicht in der Lage ist, diese 16-Bit-Instruktion optimal auszuführen. Und seitdem ist halt das schnelle Ausführen von Legacy Code eine der wichtigen Design-Vorgaben für X86-kompatible Prozessoren geworden.
Vielleicht sagen wir noch mal was zum Stichwort CISC und RISC sagen, wo das schon mal gefallen ist. CISC-CPUs sind solche mit komplexen Befehlsatz. Das heißt, es gibt viele Befehle und die Operanden der Befehle können sehr komplex sein. Also man kann direkt auf den Speicher zugreifen, kann auf den Speicher über ein Register indiziert zugreifen und so weiter auf zwei Speicherzellen gleichzeitig. Und bei einer CISC-CPU ist es so, dass es Befehle für Load und Store gibt. Das heißt, für das Schreiben in den Speichern und das Lesen aus den Speichern an Register. Und sämtliche weitere Instruktionen arbeiten auf Register und sämtliche Register sind gleichberechtigt.
A110, ich kann uns nicht heulerter aussehen, later.
Hans ist jetzt gerade gewechselt. Also wechselt gerade zum richtigen Ziel.
Es gibt auch noch eine Diskussion im Lattenzaun Chaos Radio und im ERC Channel. Frag mich jetzt bitte nicht, welcher Server.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Tja, es gibt ja noch ein paar Neuigkeiten. Da mach ich euch jetzt mal ein bisschen Hive drauf. Das erzähle ich dann nachher. Was den Chaos Computer Club hier in Berlin betrifft.
Noch was Schönes. Was ist jetzt mit den Prozessoren? Also den Entwicklungsprozess der Prozessoren hatten wir gerade. Jetzt sind eine Menge Fragen zu den Unterschieden und den Anwendungsmöglichkeiten, was es so gibt und welche Fehler die schlimmsten sind. Erzähl mal.
Ja, wir hatten ja gerade den AMD. Wie heißt denn diese dritte Inselbude? Genau, Cyrix.
Kennst du die?
Hans hat seinen Kopfhörer beiseite gelegt und taucht in die weltweiten Datennetze ein. Wir waren ja vorhin bei dieser Intel-Geschichte vor allem stehen geblieben. Ich muss noch mal kurz zusammenreißen. IBM hat sich irgendwann mal entschlossen für diesen IBM-Personalkomputer, von dem sie eigentlich keine Ahnung hatten, weil sie sowas eigentlich auch gar nicht bauen wollten. Aber nur weil Apple mit seinem, nämlich mit dem Apple II, so viel Erfolg gehabt hat, sahen sie sich genötig, da eine Antwort auf den Markt zu werfen. Das taten sie dann auch Anfang der 80er Jahre eben mit dem IBM PC. Dieser Name ist sozusagen der Grund dafür, dass man PCs halt auch wirklich so nennt. Weil der Begriff vorher zwar von Apple versucht wurde, den zu besetzen, aber das ist ihm dann doch irgendwie aus der Hand geglitten. Also da im PC versteht man halt heute einen zu dem original IBM PC-kompatiblen Rechner. Und das ist ja auch mit den heutigen Rechnern im Prinzip immer noch so. Und genau das ist auch das Problem. Das liegt vor allem an den Prozessoren. Am Anfang wurde eben der 8088 verwendet. Die langsamere Variante noch von dem 8086, der zumindest schon so ein bisschen 16-bit war. Und in der Folge hat Intel halt konsequent, naja konsequent möchte ich das nicht nennen, aber zumindest kontinuierlich diese Prozessorfamilie weiterentwickelt und immer Kompatibilität zum ersten System beibehalten. Dann kam der 80186, der 80286, der fand dann in dem Nachfolge-Modell von dem IBM PC Verwendung den IBM PC AT, da stand für Advanced Technology und alle waren unglaublich begeistert, dass die Maschine mittlerweile 6 MHz irgendwie losrannte.
Aber schon damals war das mit der Betriebssystemwahl, das war heftig kritisiert worden und die gesamte Szene hat gestört über dieses MS-DOS, das auch jetzt noch begleitet.
Was nicht dazu geführt hat, dass es dann irgendwann keiner mehr benutzt. Das wird uns glaube ich noch ewig verfolgen. Mit der 80286 war insofern schon mal ein massiver Fortschritt, als dass man damit auch irgendwie halbwegs brauchbare Betriebssysteme fahren konnte.
Der hatte eine MMU, ne?
Der hatte so eine Art MMU, würde ich mal sagen.
Der hatte eine MMU, eine richtige MMU.
Mit den Segmentregistern.
Segmentprotection und alles, was du brauchst um ein Betriebssystem auf einem Computer zu installieren. Richtig, es war etwas brandet, aber es war schon ziemlich cool für die damalige Zeit.
286er hatte ich auch mal. Habe ich dann Xenix installiert. Das ist so eine Unix-Variante, die speziell an den 80286er angepasst worden ist. Damals war es sowieso sehr trendy darüber nachzudenken, ein speziell auf den 80286er Prozessor zugeschnittenes Betriebssystem zu machen. Zum Beispiel gab es da dieses Projekt OS2. Ihr erinnert euch vielleicht, was man als Nachfolger für MS-DOS gedacht war. Damals saß halt Microsoft noch zusammen mit IBM hinter dem Pult und hat versucht, dafür die Zukunft zu planen. Das haben sie dann auch groß angekündigt. Super, OS2. Kam dann auch irgendwann raus, aber so recht hat es keinen interessiert, weil es da eben so diverse Schwierigkeiten gab mit der Kompatibilität. Ein Wort, was der Computerindustrie damals selber eigentlich noch wirklich überhaupt nicht so bewusst war, was sie sich da eigentlich mit eingebrockt haben, dass sie irgendwie so schlecht gestartet sind mit diesem PC. Na gut, egal. OS2 gab es und nach dem 82-86er gab es dann den 386er, der in gewisser Hinsicht ein wirklicher Meilenstein war, weil es sich hier jetzt um einen richtigen 32-Bit-Prozessor handelte, mit dem man einen viel größeren Speicherbereich adressieren konnte, was die Softwareerstellung einfacher machte. Auch die MMU hat da noch mal einen Schritt nach vorne gemacht.
Naja, nach vorne. Also genau genommen sind sie eingeknickt. Weil alle Paging-MMUs zu der Zeit haben wollten, haben sie dann unter diese Segment-MMU noch eine Paging-MMU drunter geholt.
Naja, aber immerhin gab es jetzt Paging. Und es gab den Real-Mode und den Protected-Mode. Man konnte den Prozessor nämlich umschalten zwischen 80-86-Kompatibilität und etwas mehr Speichern. Im Wesentlichen hat man dabei halt die MMU ein- und ausgeschaltet.
Eine MMU, wie man es schon hat?
Eine MMU ist eine Memory Management Unit. Das sollte man vielleicht nochmal erläutern. Das ist also ein weiterer Bestandteil eines Prozessors. Mittlerweile ist es Standard, damals war es eben noch kein Standard. Der, wie formuliere ich das jetzt am besten, der Software ein bequemeres Umgehen mit dem Speicher erlaubt. Ein wesentliches Problem war vorher, vielleicht soll ich das jetzt mal aufkrauen.
Die sind aber gut.
Die sind echt schlimm. Dann lass mal weg tun. Hier, komm, Lutz, zeig mal. Das macht uns nur krank und dicke Bäuche. Mit einer Memory Management Unit hat man den Vorteil, dass man nicht mehr an die Speicheradressen absolut gebunden war. Früher war es so im So, da hatte man einen bestimmten Speicherbereich von 0 bis N, je nachdem, wie viel Kilobytes man hatte. Damals eher Kilobytes, wenn überhaupt Kilobytes. Manche haben auch nur ein paar Bites gehabt. Ein Programm muss diesen Speicher irgendwie adressieren, sprich, ihn ansprechen, um ihn auszulesen, was reinzuschreiben, das miteinander zu multiplizieren, hin und herzuschieben, was ein Prozessor den ganzen Tag macht, wenn er nichts weiter zu tun hat. Das funktioniert wunderbar, wenn man nur ein einziges Programm auf dem Computer fährt, was mit dem Speicher machen kann, was es will. Aber das wird natürlich zu dem Zeitpunkt schwierig, wo man mehr als ein Programm unabhängig voneinander laufen lassen möchte. Also Multi-User-Systeme, so wie Unix, haben das Problem relativ früh aufgebracht. Bei MS-DOS und bzw. dann dieser ganzen Windows-Geschichte kann man dann auch irgendwie auf den Trichter, das vielleicht ja ganz praktisch wäre, die zur Verfügung stehende Processing-Power auch mal dahingehend zu nutzen, dass man eben mehr als einen Benutzer auf das System lässt, bzw. mehrere Dinge gleichzeitig tun kann.
Ich glaube, DeskView war das erste Programm, das es gemacht hat, das dann sozusagen mehrere DOS gleichzeitig hat laufen lassen können.
Oh ja, das war richtig ausgefeilt.
Das Problem, das will ich nochmal kurz darauf eingehen, das Problem war ja, wenn dieser Sprecher direkt angesprochen wird, also ich schreibe an Adresse 4500, schreibe ich was rein, und dann läuft ein anderes Programm, was einfach auch meint, naja, also 4500 ist eigentlich eine coole Adresse, das gefällt mir auch, da schreibe ich auch mal was rein, die Programme wissen nix voneinander, da gibt es halt Müll. Das ist der Grund, warum Macintosh-Programme auch heute noch abstürzen. Und mit der MMU kann man halt auf Prozessorebene einen Modus einschalten, wo jedes Programm seine eigene Sicht von Adressen hat, nämlich die virtuelle Speicheradresse, das ist das, was man dann Virtual Memory nennt, und die wird dann von dem Prozessor on the fly ohne Zeitverlust umgesetzt auf die tatsächliche physikalische Adresse. Also das Programm glaubt, es schreibt in 4500, aber der Prozessor rechnet halt nochmal 20.000 drauf, und dann ist es tatsächlich in anderer Speicherbereiche, und somit kommt sich die Software nicht mehr ins Gehege. Also im MMU ist dann wirklich ein Fortschritt gewesen in der Prozessorentwicklung, und wie gesagt, mittlerweile Standard.
MMU bietet natürlich noch ein anderes Feature, und zwar kann man Adressen vergeben, die gar nicht wirklich existieren, sondern wo man mehr RAM-Vorbau holt als da ist und den Rest dann auf Platte auslagert.
Und dann zur Laufzeit sozusagen die Sicht des Programmes auf den physikalischen Speicher ändern kann. Aber das sind natürlich alles nur Krücken. Ich meine, ich bin genau genommen wie mein...
der Speicher.
Und Thomas fragt im Chat, warum man zwei DOS gleichzeitig laufen lassen will, wenn eins schon reicht.
Also eine klassische Anwendung waren tatsächlich Mailboxen, weil Computer waren echt teuer, aber es gab Multiserielle. Es gab schon im Artier bis zwei serielle Schnittstellen. Und da wollte man auf beiden Ports eine Mailbox laufen lassen, aber es gab kein Multitasking. Also musste man irgendwie eine FIDU-Mailbox nehmen und die zweimal auf dem gleichen Rechner starten können. Und dafür war DeskView echt cool.
Da kannte ich auch jemanden, da lief dann noch Novel, NetWare, zwei irgendwas und zwei oder drei 80 Megabyte Platten und ein paar zwei 86er.
Also DeskView war sozusagen das erste System, was das ausgenutzt hat, wenn man mal von OS2 abzieht. Bei PC's. Genau, also DeskView hat halt einfach zweimal DOS gemacht, während OS2 versucht halt einmal was anderes zu machen.
Also die haben das dann irgendwann auch gelassen, die haben dann sich nicht mehr damit beschäftigt.
Naja, nachdem dann Windows 3.0 rauskam, wo das dann eingebaut war.
Aber wir waren jetzt gerade ziemlich in die MMOs abgeblitten.
Ja genau, aber ich meine, das ist natürlich kein uninteressanter Punkt, weil wenn wir sagen Computer on a Chip, so wie damals der erste Prozessor angekündigt wurde, kommt man ja eigentlich erst auf den Punkt, was macht denn jetzt eigentlich den Computer eigentlich aus? Also wenn der Computer nicht on a Chip war vorher, woraus bestand der denn eigentlich? Das haben wir ja glaube ich mal zusammengerissen, also so die Fähigkeit Speicher zu adressieren, gehört eigentlich gar nicht mal unbedingt dazu. Und peu a peu kommen halt auch noch andere Features mit rein. Die MMO ist die eine. Eine andere Sache ist das, was bis vor kurzem noch als Co-Prozessor bekannt war.
Oh ja.
Ein Co-Prozessor ist halt noch ein Prozessor, der in dem Computer drin steckt, der sich sozusagen neben den anderen so anlehnt und irgendwie ihm bestimmte Sachen abnimmt, nämlich im Wesentlichen Fließkomma-Arendmetik, also das Rechnen nicht mit Integer, mit Ganzzahlen, was irgendwie ganz einfach sich in Bals abspeichern lässt, sondern eben Nachkommastellenzahlen, so wie 1 durch 3, die halt irgendwie sehr lang sind, die man so in Integer auch nicht problemlos abspeichern kann, aber mit denen man halt rechnen möchte. Und dann hat man eben einen Floating-Point-Prozessor genommen, der eine ganz andere Darstellung im Speicher gehabt hat von den Zahlen, eben so auf Nachkomma orientiert, der eine gewisse Ungenauigkeit hatte, ganz klar, aber mit dem man eben sehr viel effektiver damit rechnen konnte. Das war natürlich dann sehr wichtig für so aufkommende Computeranwendungen, wie zum Beispiel CAD, also das Konstruieren von technischen Zeichnungen und ähnliche Geschichten, Bootlinien und Kreise und andere Dinge, dreidimensionales heutzutage auch berechnet werden musste. Und so ist auch eine FPU, eine Floating-Point-Unit, mittlerweile bestand an jedes Prozessor. Ansonsten ist jedes Desktop-Prozessor. Es gibt natürlich auch noch Prozessoren ohne.
Da hat sich Intel auch voll in den Messen gesetzt. Der erste Co-Prozessor für den 8086 war der 8087 und der wurde in Israel entwickelt. Und die Leute von Intel haben nicht wirklich mit dem Team kommunizieren können wegen der bösen Zeitverschiebung und so weiter. Damals gab es auch noch nicht so richtig viel Internet. Auf jeden Fall ist es so, dass die Floating-Point-Architektur bei Intel-CPUs auch heute noch stackbasiert ist. Das heißt, man hat einen Stack von 8 Einträgen und Operationen können immer nur auf dem obersten Eintrag stattfinden. Im Vergleich dazu, moderne CPUs haben 32 Floating-Point-Register und Operationen können auf jedem dieser Register ausgefüllt werden. Und es ist völlig klar, dass man damit deutlich weniger Speicherzugriffen auskommen und wesentlich flexibler ist. Und es ist also auch heute so, dass Intel-CPUs, die natürlich immer noch zum 8087 kompatibel sind, wie sollte es anders sein, nach Floating-Point-Performance ziemlich hinterher hängen. Also Pentium liegt, glaube ich, so im Bereich von 6 bis 7 Speck FP95. Das ist so der aktuelle Benchmark für Floating-Point-Performance. Und vergleichbare CPUs, der 10.000 von MIPS zum Beispiel, liegt bei 19 Speck FP95, also gleich das Doppelte. Und die von Digital jetzt angekündigte CPU, die neueste Generation des Alpha-Prozessors, liegt bei 50 Speck FP, also der 5-fachen Leistung.
Das Speck FP ist so ein normalisierter Standardwert aktueller Benchmark, der wieder so wie MIPS eigentlich gar nicht so viel aussagt, außer dass dieses C-Programm eben in einer entsprechenden Geschwindigkeit ausgefüllt wird. Aber man muss ja hinterher immerhin zugute halten, dass sie auf ihrem hirntoten Floating-Point-Performance immer noch die schnellsten CPUs bauen. Und das ist auch der Grund, warum sie da momentan ziemlich stinken und gegen ihre Konkurrenten auch so ziemlich gut dastehen, weil diesen Krankenbefehlssatz, den kriegt man nicht so einfach implementiert. Und bislang sind noch alle Versuche, eine FPU zu konstruieren, die Intel-Code versteht und schneller ist, als die Intel-FPUs sind eigentlich gescheitert. Integer ist nicht so das Problem, das kriegt man heutzutage hin. Aber Floating Point, da haben sie sich beim Pentium schon richtig was ausgedacht und da haben auch alle Ovo gesagt bei der FPU. Bei welcher?
Aber von Pentium? Ja, bei der Pentium. Was haben sie sich denn ausgedacht?
Da gibt es zum Beispiel so Laufzeit abhängige Berechnungen, dass sie die Signallaufzeit verwenden, um eine bestimmte Winkelfunktion auszurechnen. Irgend so ein Ding, das kann Andreas bestimmt besser...
Ich hab es mir auch nicht im Detail angeguckt, weil es mich doch eher abgeschränkt hat.
Aber dann machen sie richtig miese Tricks, wo die digitalen Tricks also echte Probleme haben und einfach nicht so schnell hinterher rechnen können.
Also ich glaube, miese Tricks sind sowieso irgendwie...
Abdeckung, miese Tricks. Intel hat sich ja MMX ausgedacht.
Das ist was ganz besonders Tolles.
Vielleicht sollte man zu abwechselnd mal erklären, was MMX wirklich ist. Normalerweise, wenn man 2 32-Bit-Zahlen addiert, hat man immer einen Übertrag. Das heißt, man addiert 2 Bit ganz rechts und den Übertrag zieht man dann eins nach links, so wie man auch schriftlich addiert. Alles, was sie da machen, ist, den Übertrag an bestimmten Stellen abzuschalten, sodass man 2 32-Bit-Werte addieren kann, so wie man sich jeweils 2 16-Bit-Werte insgesamt 4 verhalten kann. Oder man kann 8-Bit auf 8-Bit addieren, mit dem man 2 32-Bit-Werte aufeinander addiert. Das ist für manche Sachen ein bisschen sinnvoll. Das Problem dabei ist, man kann es nur in Assembler programmieren, man kann keinen vernünftigen Compiler schreiben, der das verwenden kann. Und es ist so, dass die Konkurrenz, nämlich die PowerPC, CPUs, ohne MMX dieselbe Aufgabe schneller lösen.
Ja gut, ich meine, das wäre ja noch zu verschmerzen, weil das Blöde an den MMX-Befehlen ist tatsächlich, dass sie sozusagen mit den FPU-Befehlen interlieft implementiert sind, sodass der Befehlssatz quasi umgeschaltet werden muss.
Genau, weil ich nicht gleichzeitig MMX und Floating Pointe und Kissen total gönne.
Das ist unglaublich.
Ja, aber das mit diesem Scheiß-Befehlssatz, da haben sie sich richtig neigelegt und wo sie jetzt... Also da müssen sie echte Handstände füllen, um da was dran zu tun.
Auf der anderen Seite kaufen alle MMX und alle anderen müssen jetzt auch MMX anbauen. Und ich glaube, diese Entwickler, die aber am D sitzen, die kotzen irgendwie. Wenn die morgens einen Press-Relief von Ickl auf den Tisch kriegen, irgendwie Hilton Announcers, New MMX Extensions, dann wissen die irgendwie, dass sie das nächste halbe Jahr auch keinen Spaß haben werden. Weil sie erstmal diese ganze Scheiße da rausboden müssen und dann auch noch einen Weg finden müssen, dann müssen wir das ganze halbwegs, ohne jetzt gleich die Chips abzukratzen, auch noch implementieren.
Voll sinnlos, weil es nie jemand wirklich benutzen wird.
Und dann kriegt man es vielleicht hin, und dann kriegen sie erstmal wieder eine Klage auf Patentverletzungen oder sonst...
Apropos Patente. Intel kommt jetzt mit einer neuen Architektur, der Merced-Chip mit 64-Bit. Und Intel hat erstmal ein paar Sachen patentieren lassen für den Merced. Das erste, was sie sich haben patentieren lassen, sind Opcodes, um zwischen verschiedenen Befehlssätzen umzuschalten. Also diese Merced-CPU, das muss man sich mal vor Augen halten, wird x86-Befehlssatz verstehen, wird den Befehlssatz der HP-Architektur PRist verstehen und wird zusätzlich einen neuen Befehlssatz, den sogenannten EPIC-Befehlssatz verstehen. Also da werden allein 2 Millionen Transistoren für nichts drauf gebraucht werden.
Ja, wofür müssten sie die ganzen Transistoren ja verwenden? Du zeigst darum irgendwie... Da werden bestimmt auch noch Spark sein.
Das würde mich echt nicht wundern.
Also haben die einen abschaltbaren Micro-Code-Prozessor in der CPU drin, sodass sie wahlweise RISC und SISC machen können?
Also ich kann mir das nur so erklären, dass da die Micro-Code-Befehlssätze umgeschaltet werden.
Hier ist Matthias.
Hallo Matthias.
Ich habe mal eine Frage. Wisst ihr vielleicht, wann die ersten Systeme mit 100 MHz Busstakt auf den Markt kommen?
Du meinst jetzt Mainboard Busstakt?
Ja genau, und passende Prozessoren.
Tja, da kann man jetzt nur ein bisschen spekulieren. Ich glaube, sie sind gerade so bei 80.
83 glaube ich, ja. Es gibt natürlich schon etwas länger Systeme mit 100 MHz Busstakt, allerdings nicht für den Konsumermarkt, und länger als ein Jahr wird das bestimmt nicht dauern. Es wird die Treadraten voranschreiten.
Ja, ich denke auch, das geht gerade richtig rasant.
Also jetzt momentan Computer kaufen, ist eigentlich immer falsch. Man sollte 2000 Mark ausgeben, mehr nicht.
Man sollte auch grundsätzlich immer noch zwei Jahre warten. Auch zwei Jahre später.
Im Chat wird gelegentlich nach der 1 GHz CPU gefragt. Das ist ja was Ähnliches.
500 MHz ist glaube ich so das, was jetzt erstmal ansteht für den nächsten. Also ein GHz Labor.
Na ja, das hängt von der CPU ab. Alphas werden schon mit 500 MHz in Stückzahlen ausgeliefert. Die neue Alpha-Generation fängt mit 633 MHz an. Und es gibt bereits Labormuster mit 1 GHz.
Ich schätze mal 3 Jahre. Matthias?
Ja, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen hochgegriffen, denke ich jetzt noch.
Wir wechseln jetzt auch zwei, bringen jetzt zwei Sachen zusammen. Du hast ja nach dem Bustakt gefragt, sollte man vielleicht nochmal kurz erläutern. Das ist halt der Takt, mit dem der Prozessor auf alle anderen Komponenten in dem Computersystem auf dem Mainboard zugreift. Der ist natürlich ganz erheblich dafür entscheidend, wie die Gesamtperformance des Systems ist. Und das andere ist der Takt des Prozessors selber für seine internen Operationen. Aber jedes Mal, wenn er nach draußen gehen muss, müssen ja auch alle anderen irgendwie mitspielen und reagieren. Und irgendwie eine Chance haben zu verstehen, was der Prozessor eigentlich erzählt.
Bustakt, das werden wir im Wesentlichen für die Speicher-Performance und für die Grafik-Performance in dem Moment verantworten.
Das war deine Frage.
Ja, und dann habe ich noch eine andere Frage. Und zwar zu Grafikchips. Kennt ihr euch da auch ein bisschen aus? Und zwar, ich habe Interesse einer Grafikkarte mit dem Riva 128.
Nie gehört.
Zum Game oder was? Willst du damit spielen oder was willst du damit machen? Na ja, alles kannst du damit nicht machen, weil die aktuellen Grafikchips alle viel zu geringe Auflösungen haben für Sachen, die man wirklich machen möchte. Aber ich meine, die sind schon ziemlich geil für Spiele. Also diese aktuellen 3D-beschleunigten Geschichten, die sind schon amtlich. Aber wie gesagt, das Problem ist halt immer die Auflösungen. Und wenn du mit Fernsehqualität für das, was du machen willst, zufrieden bist, dann kannst du jetzt wirklich auf eine der aktuellen, also auch eine Viva-Karte kommen, sprich nichts dagegen.
Ich hab da eigentlich eher in der Richtung, wie weit die CPU entlasten.
Die CPU-Chips, also...
Na ja, das hängt sehr von der Software ab, des Betriebssystems. Also diese CPU-Entlastung, die da immer proklamiert wird, das ist halt so eine Sache. Und man muss da auch nicht unbedingt alles klauen.
Also es soll da die nächsten Grafik-CPUs mit Triangulierer kommen. Also, dass die Triangulierung mehr von dem Grafikchips als gemacht wird, das ist im Moment halt nicht der Fall.
Ja, das soll eben dieser Riva 128 ziemlich gut machen.
Also ich würde doch da eher die CT befreuen, als den Chaos Computer Club.
Wir wissen jetzt Nachrichten von Matthias.
Irakkonflikt. US-Außenministerin Albright will in der Nacht nach Europa fliegen, um in Paris, Moskau und London für eine harte Linie zu werben. Albright drohte am Abend erneut mit einem militärischen Schlag gegen den Irak, falls die UNO-Waffeninspekteure nicht ungehinderten Zugang zu allen Einrichtungen bekämen. Großbritannien unterstützt den Irak-Kurs Washington's, während Frankreich und Russland auf eine Verhandlungslösung setzen. Baufelsaffäre. Der unter Korruptionsverdacht stehende Potsdamer Baustadtrat Kaminski muss seinen Posten räumen. Das Stadtparlament stimmt mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit für die Amtsenthebung. Kaminski wird Vorteilsnahme im Amt vorgeworfen. EU-Strafe. Der VW-Konzern muss wegen unzulässiger Verkaufspraktiken eine Geldbusse von über 200 Millionen Mark zahlen. VW will die Geldstrafe nicht akzeptieren und kündigte eine Klage beim Europäischen Gerichtshof an. Nordirland-Konflikt. Ohne Ergebnis ist heute in London eine weitere Verhandlungsrunde über die Zukunft der Provinz beendet worden. Kernpunkt der Gespräche ist eine britisch-erische Friedensinitiative. Martina Ertl hat wenige Tage vor Beginn der Olympischen Winterspiele den ersten Nachtriesensladeum im schwedischen Are gewonnen. Zweite wurde die Schweizerin Sonja Neff, dritte wurde die Schwedin Anna Ottosson. Fußball. Rund fünf Monate vor Beginn der Weltmeisterschaft hat die französische Nationalmannschaft gegen Spanien mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Das Testspiel vor 80.000 Zuschauern war der Höhepunkt der Eröffnungsfeier des neuen WM-Stadions in Saint-Denis, 10 km nördlich von Paris. Nachts aufgelockerte Bewölkung, minus 5 bis minus 10 Grad. Achtung, Glätte durch überfrierende Nässe am Tage, niederschlagsfrei, minus 1 bis 3 Grad. Verkehr. Berlin-Wilmersdorf. Die Brandenburgische Straße ist zwischen Mannheimer und Berliner Straße wegen eines Feuereinsatzes in beiden Richtungen gesperrt. A111 Stadtautobahn Charlottenburg Richtung Oranienburg. Der Tunnel Tegel-Ortskern ist gesperrt. Eine Umleitung ist ausgewiesen. Und Brandenburg-Potztamm im gesamten Bereich Glättebildung durch überfrierende Nässe, insbesondere auf Bundesautobahnen und Bundesstraßen. Stellenweise Sichtweiten unter 50 Meter Fahrt. Bitte vorsichtig.
Das war das Krupsinfo mit Kassenkoch. Das Chaosradio in Blue Moon am Mittwoch, jeden letzten Mittwoch im Monat, im übrigen bei Fritz im Radio zu hören. Andreas, Tim und Franz sind hier im Studio mit jede Menge Hörer rufen an. Wollen wir gleich weitermachen mit Telefonieren? Oder hattest du noch ein Announcement?
Hab ich auch noch, aber lass uns doch nochmal ein paar Hörer reinnehmen und ich werde das dann nochmal einbringen.
Ah, ja, den hör ich auch, der ist auch da. Hallo, wer ist da?
Ja, hallo, mein Name ist Martin, ich rufe aus Berlin-Friedrichshain an. Und ich höre euch... Hallo?
Ja, sprich uns weiter.
Ich höre euch die ganze Zeit so nett zu, wie ihr da über Dosen klautert. Und sag mal, habt ihr denn nicht schonmal was von der englischen Firma Archon und deren RISC Prozessoren gehört? Die bauen die ja mittlerweile schon seit über 10 Jahren. Hier steht einer.
Ach, Archon RISC Machine, es ist durchaus bekannt. Soll auch nicht unerwähnt bleiben. Wir schreien uns immer so schnell wieder vom Thema ab. Ihr kommt recht. Also gerade im RISC-Markt war Archon sehr zukunftsweisend, gerade mit dem Archimedes. Hast du einen Archimedes?
Nee, ich hab jetzt hier einen RISC-PC zu stehen mit einem Strong-Arm SA110 Prozessor von Digital. Ja, RISC aus 3.7 nennt sich das Archon eigene Betriebssystem.
Ahja, also dasselbe, was auf dem Archimedes lief, oder wie?
Ja, im Prinzip RISC 2.3, eine Weiterentwicklung davon, das ist korrekt.
Programmierst du das Ding direkt oder programmierst du den Ziel?
Ich programmiere den Wendern überhaupt zur Zeit in Basic, der hat einen eingebauten Basic Interpreter, ziemlich mächtig, da kann man auch ganz direkt dann, also er hat auch einen eingebauten Inland, den ich noch nicht so stark benutze, das ist natürlich sehr super, weil die Armsprache direkt kann man total frei programmieren, also da lässt sich jeder Befehl bedingt ausführen, man braucht nicht irgendwelche langen Compare und Registerneuladeschleifen oder so, das ist schon zukunftsweisend.
Was klasse ist an dem Ding ist ja vor allem, dass es halt so in der Tradition von den Heimcomputern der 80er Jahre steht, das heißt, das hat halt eine richtige Maschine, die kennt man vollständig und da gibt es halt das Basic, mit dem macht man, wenn man irgendwie so ein kleines Anwendungsprogramm machen will oder mal ausprobieren will, wie das geht, macht man so vor sich hin und wenn man dann irgendwann mal Speed braucht, dann programmiert man das Ding einfach in Assembler ohne irgendwelche Nervereien, sondern eben so wie auf dem Arm jetzt sogar mit einem Inline-Assembler. Sowas wollte man früher halt auch schon immer haben. Früher war das auch nicht so mal. Deathpack-Assembler-Booten von Cassette und so.
Der Strong-Arm-Chip ist sowieso ein sehr interessanter Chip. Die Firma AMD, Entschuldigung, die Firma Arm, Archon Risk Machines, die den gebaut hat, die mittlerweile bei Digital untergekommen ist, und Gott sind die jetzt auch bei Compaq.
Das ist noch nicht passiert.
Ja okay, das ist noch nicht passiert, aber ich glaube, es wird sich da wenig verändern. Außerdem sind da teilweise auch so Lizenzrechte an Intel jetzt verkauft worden. Alles ganz grausam, ist auch egal. Dieser Prozessor wurde irgendwie Anfang letzten Jahres, Mitte letzten Jahres, vor dem halben Jahr war das glaube ich ungefähr, ein Prozessor-Show in den USA, der Strong Arm haben sie dem Prozessor gezeigt. Und zwar haben sie da einen Benchmark drauf laufen lassen, also lief halt irgendwas und daneben lief ein Pentium. Und die waren beide gleich schnell. Soweit nichts besonderes. Das Besondere war, dass die Stromversorgung dieses Strong Arm Chips, die wurde halt ge... Chaos Radio Kurzmeldung Berlin. Nachdem der Berliner Radiosender 100, 6 auf seiner Frequenz unfreiwillig eine Falschmeldung über das vorzeitige Ableben unseres geliebten Innensenators erdulden musste, hat nun auch ein McDonalds, an der A15 in Holland arge Probleme mit sogenannten Funk-Piraten. Die drahtlose Sprechanlage des Drive-In wird offenbar regelmäßig von einem Funke heimgesucht, der die Bestellung nachträglich etwas korrigiert, was Kunden und Personal zur Verzweiflung bringt. Ob die angedrohte Anzeige oder technische Maßnahmen zum Erfolg führen, ist eher ungewiss. Japan, der bisher bizarreste Fall von geistiger Beschädigung durch Fernsehen, wird aus dem Land der aufgehenden Sonne gemeldet. Eine stroboskopartige Folge sehr heller Bilder in einem Zeichentrick-Film löste offenbar ungewöhnliche neurologische Reaktionen bei hunderten von Zuschauern aus. Die Betroffenen wurden mit Krämpfen, Transzuständen und Schwindelgefühlen in Krankenhäuser eingetiefert. Der Sender versprach vor künftigen Folgen der Reihe, eine Warnung zu senden. Amiland, eine bestimmte Sorte Herzschrittmacher, kann durch einen Bug in der Software bei seinen Trägern Herzrasen verursachen. Die Herstellerfirma hat einen Bug-Fix entwickelt, der vom Arzt per drahtloser Übertragung in den Schrittmacher eingespielt wird. Das Bekanntwerden dieser Art des Fixes löste einige Diskussionen über die Sicherheitsmechanismen aus, mit denen so ein Update authentifiziert wird. Die externe drahtlose Wartung implantierter Geräte ist mittlerweile für Herzschrittmacher, Hörgeräte und ähnliche Hardware-Erweiterungen Standard geworden. Aber don't try this at home. Großdeutsches Blockwartreich. Zum regelmäßigen Drogentest müssen Schüler einer Privatschule in Schwerin. Auf einstimmigen Beschloss von Eltern und Lehrern wird jeden Monat ein Schüler zum beaufsichtigten Pinkeln ausgelost. Weigert sich der oder die Betreffende ist ein Rauswurf fällig, werden wiederholt Drogenspuren gefunden auch. Offenbar ist die Elite in Schwerin der Meinung, dass der im Grundgesetz verankerte vorrangige Schutz der Würde und Selbstbestimmung des Menschen erst ab 18 gilt. Etliche Medikamente und auch einige Nahrungsmittel ergeben in Urin-Tests einen positiven Drogenbefund. Aber das hat sich wohl auch noch nicht bis nach McPom durchgesprochen. Washington, Weißes Haus, Oral Office. Um seine Mitbürger davon abzulenken, dass er mal wieder den Hosenschlitz in Gegenwart einer jüngeren Untertane nicht zulassen konnte, veranstaltet Bill Clinton derzeit einige Vorbereitungen für das nächste Hoseinschießen am Golf. Das Merkwürdige an den Durchsäckern in Diskussionen darüber, welche neuen Hightech-Waffen denn nun eingesetzt werden sollen, ist die Geheimhaltungspraxis. Die Kommandeure beschweren sich darüber, dass die Waffen so geheim sind, dass sie gar nicht wissen, was für Wirkungen sie haben und wie sie am besten eingesetzt werden sollen. Eine ganz neue Variante des NAFU-Prinzips. Unbestätigten Gerüchten zufolge wurde der Chefleibwächter von Clinton in die engere Auswahl für den Friedensnobelpreis aufgenommen, nachdem er vorgeschlagen hatte, Clintons Hosenschlitze mit Sicherheitsschlössern auszustatten. Die Schlüssel würden dann von ihrer Frau Hillary verwalten.
Test, Test.
Also die Hörer kommen nicht so richtig an die Leitung?
Doch, einer ist dran. Wer ist denn dort? Wie geht's dir?
Ich bin Olaf.
Welche Frage hast du denn zu Prozessoren?
Na cool, die haben uns aus der Leitung vorher gekickt. Ey Olaf, Frage loswerden. Na klar, ich bin dran. Jaja, in der Logo.
Ist eine Party, oder?
Nee, wir sitzen gerade mit dem Spiel Shadow Warrior. Ey Tim, Freitagspflege-Straße?
Ja, natürlich.
Oh, ey, mach den Radius weg.
Ey Lola, Frage.
Habt ihr auch noch eine Frage zur Sendung?
Ja klar, Lola wollte eigentlich was fragen.
Also sie traut sich offensichtlich auch nicht wirklich.
Er holt sich gerade Kissen über den Kopf.
Okay, schicken wir eine Mail.
Haben Kissen auch Pins? Können Kissen auch Pins haben?
Na ja, also das glaube ich, wir werden das erleben. Es gibt derzeit ganz stark den Trend in der Textilindustrie, in jedes Kleidungsstück und sicherlich demnächst auch in jede andere Textilie einen Chip einzubauen. Ganz allgemein zur besseren Verwaltung der Lagerhaltung, feststellen, welche Dinge denn nun wirklich entspunden und geklaut worden sind, automatische Erkennung. Das Problem ist, dass man sozusagen irgendwann in den nächsten Jahren fast mit jedem Kleidungsstück dann auch noch gleich einen Computer mit im Hosenbund hat, der auch noch fernabfragbar ist. Genau, und wir empfehlen jedes Kleidungsstück, nachdem er es gekauft hat, erstmal in eine halbe Stunde in die Mikrowelle zu stecken, wobei noch nicht so ganz klar ist, ob das dann auch wirklich den gewünschten Effekt hat.
Ich glaube zwei Sekunden reichen und haben den gewünschten Effekt.
Alles klar, also speist alle eure Klamotten, die er gerade gekauft hat, am besten mal in die Mikrowelle. Ich habe das nicht gesagt.
Ja, aber zum Thema, wo sonst noch überall CPUs drin stecken, in Chipkarten sind auch teilweise CPUs drin. Uns erreichen öfter Anfragen, ja, kann man GSM-Karten kopieren, kann man DF1-Karten kopieren und die Antwort ist nein. Aber, und zwar kann man sie nicht kopieren, indem man das Chipkarteninterface anspricht. Man redet nämlich mit dieser Chipkarte ein Protokoll, da steckt eine CPU drin, da läuft ein Programm drauf, man schickt ein Request hin, kriegt eine Antwort. Wenn man diese Karte auslesen will, muss man sie rumdrehen und ein bisschen rauchende Salpetersäure drauftropfen, bis der Chip sichtbar ist. Dann muss man das Ganze abspülen, unter sein Lieblings-Elektronen-Mikroskop liegen, ein bisschen mit einem Laser auf den Adressleitung rumstechen und dann noch zwei Micro-Props drauf. Dann kann man auch einen solchen Chip auslesen. Aber mit Heilmitteln ist es einfach nicht zu machen.
Ja, das ist nichts für den Samstag nach Mittag gestalten.
Der Trick ist halt, dass die Verschlußung in dem Chip läuft und man an diesen Verschlüsselungsvorgang nicht direkt kommt, sondern nur an die Ergebnisse.
Eine Frage ist noch in Prenzlberg verschlüsselt. Paul ist am Telefon. Was hast du für eine Frage zum Thema Prozessoren?
Nicht direkt zum Thema Prozessoren eigentlich.
Frag trotzdem.
Mehr grundsätzlich an den Chaos Computer Club. Ich habe nur mehr die alten Datenschleudern gelesen und diese erste Hackerbibel im Antik-Fayard gekriegt, weil die neuen Sachen in den eigentlichen Bücherläden nicht ausliegen und die meine Mama kann sie nicht bestellen.
Wir haben da noch ein bisschen ein Problem, wo wir gerade dabei sind, das zu lösen. Zunächst einmal, was immer wieder angefragt wird, die Hackerbibel 1 und Hackerbibel 2. Die sind beide vergriffen und eine Neuauflage ist aus technischen Gründen etwas schwierig. Es gab allerdings sehr viele Anfragen danach. Deswegen sind wir dazu übergegangen, sind alle gescannt worden. Und die sind vollständig auf der Chaos CD. Die Chaos CD ist eine CD, die wir zusammengestellt haben. Die könnt ihr auch bei uns bestellen. Beim CCC in Hamburg, Schwenke Straße 85, 20255 Hamburg. Genaues dazu auch auf unserem Webserver. Da sind auch die Datensteudern bis... 57 glaube ich. Für ungefähr die ersten 50 Datenschleudern sind da auch noch mit drauf. Und noch ein bisschen anderes Zeug, LFCs, so diverser Kram. Das ist sozusagen der einfachste Weg, an die Hackerbibel ranzukommen. Die Datenschleuder wiederum, die ja viermal im Jahr erscheint, also alle drei Monate eine Ausgabe, die vertreiben wir über den gleichen Weg, beziehungsweise alle Mitglieder kriegen sowieso die Datenschleuder zugeschickt. Die kriegen auch diese Chaos-CDs, in dem Moment, wo sie eintreten. Hier in Berlin haben wir es jetzt ein bisschen einfacher gemacht, abgesehen davon, dass wir in unseren neuen Club an diesem Donnerstag treffen, im Club Discordia natürlich alles verkaufen, was wir haben. Also nicht alles verkaufen, aber zumindest die Datenschleuder und die Chaos-CD. Gibt es die Datenschleuder auch bei JF. Lehmanns im Fachbuchladen in der Hardenbergstraße.
Den werden wir ansonsten aber nicht werben, weil wir das prinzipiell nicht tun.
Genau, der aber trotzdem ziemlich gut ist.
Aber da gibt es die aktuelle Datenschleuder und auch die letzte Ausgabe, also auch die 60. Also jetzt gerade die beiden mit den vielen Bauplänen drin, die gibt es halt da zu erwärben an der Kasse.
Ja, und dann, ich meine, ich habe davon gesprochen, dass ihr sozusagen einen Stützpunkt in Berlin aufmacht oder von Hard. Richtig. Aber nicht wo der ist.
Doch, habe ich schon gesagt. Das hast du nicht mitbekommen. Ich kann es noch mal sagen. Marienstraße 11, das ist in der Mitte, in der Nähe vom Bahnhof Friedrichstraße. Stadtplan Gucken.
Hinterhof. Um die Ecke vom Bunker, falls das jemand mal sagt.
Genau, nicht weit vom Bunker. Und wie gesagt, ab dem 12. Februar, alle zwei Wochen am Donnerstag, also dann am 26.2. und die Woche draus ist dann C-Wett, und wenn wir dann weitermachen, sehen wir dann. Ja, beantwortet das die Frage?
Ja gut, naja und dann weiß ich nicht. Ich meine, habt ihr immer, ich hab nur die, wie gesagt, die erste Bibel gelesen und so. Und habt ihr immer noch diesen Anspruch sozusagen, die Welt zu, nein nicht die Welt zu verbessern, zumindest die großen Fehler aufzuzeigen, die die Computerindustrie noch nicht geschafft hat, zu bereinigen?
Na ja, also zumindest haben wir letztes Jahr, glaube ich, auf ein paar Probleme relativ erfolgreich hinweisen können. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das so mitbekommen hast.
Nein, eben nicht, weil ich da kaum Informationsmachung habe.
Ja gut, also das entnimmt man dann auch meistens auch schon irgendwie aus zweiter und dritter Hand aus der Presse zu Verlautbarungen wie zum Beispiel Jungs, die statistische Untersuchung, also die Errechenbarkeit der PIN, der EC-Karte und ähnliche Sachen.
Der CCC ist halt auch eine Vereinigung von Leuten, die sich über mehr als nur Computer unterhalten. Aber die Zuständigkeit kann da wohl irgendwie nicht beim CCC für größere Fehler gesucht werden.
Ja, weil die nicht mal so wissen, ob sich dieser Geist noch erhalten hat.
Das kannst du dann natürlich auch selber überprüfen, wenn du zu uns kommst. Wir sind aufgeschlossen, falls auch andere Leute bringen, was die jüngere Generation betrifft. Weil da ziehen halt viele Leute ran. 16-Jährige haben heute schon wissen, da drehen sich halt die Fußnägel einmal im Kreis. Das hat man auch beim Kongress gesehen. Das wäre für dich auch eine Möglichkeit. Wir machen halt einmal im Jahr den Kongress. Und dieses Jahr sind wir halt auch auf der C-Bürge.
Na gut, das war dann eigentlich frohen Mal.
Tja, die Prozessoren.
Leider funktionieren sie ja nicht immer richtig, wie man auch der Pressunternehmen entnehmen kann.
Ich nehme mal an, dass ein Versicherungsunternehmen auch nicht besonders zufrieden ist, wenn die Maschinen, die da eingesetzt werden, nicht richtig rechnen.
Naja, glücklicherweise machen die Versicherungen, dass ja mit Integer Arithmetic gerechnet. Einfach alles in Integer vernieben, haben das Problem gar nicht. Genau, ich habe noch etwas interessantes dazu gefunden, was tatsächlich dieser Bug eigentlich war. Und zwar verwendet der Pentium den sogenannten SRT-Algorithmus zum Dividieren. Das steht für Sweeney, Robertson und Tocher. Die haben sich das ausgedacht. Und das läuft darauf hinaus, dass man sich bestimmte Bits am Anfang der Zahl anguckt und in eine Tabelle nachguckt und dann bloß die unteren Bits bearbeitet. Und jetzt war es nummerweise so, dass in gewissen Grenzfällen der falsche Tabelleneintrag verwendet wurde. Es wurde einfach falsch gerundet an einer bestimmten Stelle.
Und schon war alles braun.
Genau.
Hallo, ich habe eine Frage.
Was ist denn dran an den falschen Intel-Prozessoren, die es geben soll?
Eine Menge. Gefälschter. Also nicht falsche Intel-Prozessoren, sondern eben Prozessoren, die nicht von Intel sind. Da werden halt irgendwelche Clone-Prozessoren als Intel-Pensium-Prozessoren verkauft, weil man die billiger einkaufen kann, aber dafür entsprechend tauschen kann. Die Fachzeitstufe CT ist ja immer sehr eifrig beim Aufarbeiten solcher Fälle. Mittlerweile macht man das nicht nur mit Prozessoren, sondern auch mit RAM-Chips und Grafikkontrollern und so. Da steht halt dann irgendwie was drauf, was es angeblich ist, was es tatsächlich nicht ist. Und was dann vielleicht niemand bemerkt, aber irgendwann läuft halt so dein Treiber nicht mehr. Und dann ist es natürlich ganz schön braun. Bei den Prozessoren selber ist es nicht so richtig.
Also bei Intel gibt es sicher auch Mühe, jede Baureihe mit rein fertigen technisch schwierigen Kennzeichen auszustatten. Also dazu sind sie jetzt halt übergegangen. Ein Intel-CPU komplett zu fälschen, ist einfach mit erheblichem Aufwand verbunden. Und insofern ist das nicht so das Problem, denke ich.
Gut, und wenn man jetzt sowas kauft als was, wie identifiziert man die?
Naja, ich meine, wenn es dir kein Problem macht, dann kannst du dir genau genommen egal sein. Und wenn es dir ein Problem macht und du nachweisen kannst, dass du ein Intel Pentium gekauft hast und aber tatsächlich einen Cyrix Schieß mich tot in deinem Rechner drin hast, dann gehst du zum Händler hin und sagst, den wollen wir da den Prozessor ein. Den richtigen nämlich.
Aber das andere ist betruchtet, man.
Von der rechtlichen Seite ist mir das schon klar, aber eben eben...
Ja gut, also ich empfehle dir einfach das Stöbern im CT-Archiv. Also die Zeitruf CT ist halt so diejenige, die das bisher immer irgendwie auch nach vorne gebracht hat, weil sie eigentlich auch die einzigen sind, die irgendwie überhaupt Ahnung haben von Computern im deutschen Zeitschriftenmarkt.
Alles andere kannst du gedroht in die Pfeife rauchen und die haben ihr Archiv komplett als CD, das heißt dann CT-ROM, und sie haben vor allen Dingen auf ihrem Web-Server Software zum Download mit dem man seinen Rechner sehr genau testen kann, auch wieviel RAM, wieviel Testschramm vor allen Dingen da drinnen ist und ob man vielleicht auch mehr als 64 MB reinstecken kann, ohne dass der Rechner langsam wird.
Aber genau genommen ist es natürlich für den Anwender vollkommen puken egal, ob da ein Xyrex oder ein AMD oder ein Pentium drinsteckt, weil normalerweise merkt man das nicht. Und wenn man es halt nicht merkt, dann ist es halt auch die Frage, wie man sich da Gedanken darüber machen sollte, ob das jetzt ein AMD oder ein Pentium ist.
Ja gut, aber bei diesem Grafikchip ist es natürlich schon ein Problem, weil ein anderer Grafikchip, der sich vielleicht lange Zeit erfolgreich, so wie der gefälschte nachgemacht und verhält, ist ja wunderschön, aber irgendwann mit dem nächsten Windows Betriebssystem Release, dann brauchst du erstmal wieder einen kompletten Satz neue Treiber und dann läuft das halt unter Umständen gar nicht. Ich hatte sowas früher auch mit Soundkarten, die halt alle irgendwie behaupteten, ja, wir sind Soundblaster Pro-kompatibel, sowieso, und das machten sie halt daran fest, dass sie es geschafft haben Treiber für DOS mit zu liefern, so dass irgendwie ein Programm das irgendwie richtig erkannt hat, so, aber kaum hast du das mal unter einem ordentlichen Betriebssystem installiert, dann war das halt alles braun. Also das kann schon zu Problemen führen und ich persönlich tendiere eher dazu, immer jeweils so das Original zu kaufen, weil so mit diesen Kompatibilitäten ist das beim PC ja sowieso ein Problem. Sehr viel Unfug wird auch derzeit getrieben mit Level-2-Cache, so spezieller Speicher, der den Prozessor schneller macht, da sind dann auch nicht nur die PCs von betroffen, sondern auch bei Macintoshes tritt das auf, dass halt da irgendwie schlecht das Cache-Ramme verkauft wird, was nicht so schnell ist, wie eigentlich angesagt, dass es sich einfach nicht so belastbar verhält und es gibt dann immer wieder lustige Kompatibilitäten. Da hilft aber eigentlich nur, die technische Presse darüber zu verfolgen, das ist halt, was Printmedien betrifft, ganz klar die CT und auf dem Internet gibt es da viele Quellen.
Vielleicht sollten wir gleich noch mal ein bisschen was über Caches erzählen. Und zwar ursprünglich war es halt so, die CPU hat auf den Ram zugegriffen und damals waren die CPUs noch nicht so schnell, da war das nicht das Problem. Dann hat der Ram halt irgendwann die Daten geliefert und dann war gut. Als die CPUs immer schneller wurden, kam der Ram irgendwann nicht mehr hinterher. Und die Lösung, die man sich dafür hat einfallen lassen, ist sogenanntes Cache-Ram. Das ist eine Zwischenstufe. Da wird halt in schnellerem, aber auch teureren Ram ein Subset der zuletzt benutzten Daten gespeichert und regelfalls ist es so, dass auf die alten Daten wieder zugegriffen wird und statistisch gesehen reicht es aus, wenn man nur einen gewissen Teil schnellen Speicher hat und den Rest halt langsamer hat und sich dann hier reich gebastelt.
Na ja, ich meine, genau genommen ist das begründet in den RISC-CPUs, die halt, also gut, nur zum Teil, aber im Prinzip kommt das von den RISC-CPUs, weil die CIS-CPUs sehr viel mehr Funktionalität im Prozessor drin hatten und auch darauf ausgelegt waren, dass es prinzipiell schneller geht, innerhalb der CPU irgendwas zu tun, als auf den langsamen externen Speicher zuzuleiten.
Ich. Bin gespannt, was ihr da so in der Sendung habt Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da so in der Sendung habt Ich bin gespannt, was ihr da so in der Sendung habt.
Ja, hier ist auch Fritz. Hast du eine Frage?
Ja, also nicht direkt.
Und zwar habt ihr vorhin von der CD-ROM erzählt.
Der Chaos CD?
Ja, genau.
Und ich wollte jetzt nochmal die Adresse wissen.
Und was die bestellen kann und was die kosten.
Die kann man beim Chaos Computer Club Hamburg bestellen. Was kostet die eigentlich?
42 Mark plus 8 Mark Versand.
Plus 8 Mark Versand, sprich ein Fuffi. Und die bekommst du halt beim CCC. In der Schwenke Straße 85. Schwenke mit W und CK. 85 in der Straße. 20255. Genau, tippst dir ein, dann...
Und wie muss ich das bezahlen?
Verrechnung oder Scheck oder...
Ich sag jetzt nichts falsch, dass wir die aktuellen Verkaufsmodellitäten sind. Dann hast du die Gelegenheit...
Vorauskaste.
Vorauskaste ist, glaube ich, prima. Was wollten wir nicht haben? Kein Bargeld. Genau, Scheck sind prima.
Gut, tschau.
Eine andere Leitung ist Tom aus Tempelhof. Hast du auch eine Frage?
Ja, mich würde mal interessieren. Ich bin seit Jahren schon Apple-Anwender und will mir doch einen neuen kaufen, wo die große Entwicklung, also Unterschied zwischen den 04er-Prozessoren und den G3-Prozessoren sind. Ob die wirklich deutlich schneller sind oder ob das nur ein Verkaufstrick ist, ob die Diskussion in den G3 zu investieren, anstatt einen alten 04er zu kaufen.
Ja, also, das hängt ein bisschen davon ab, was du machen willst. Würde ich zunächst einmal sagen, der G3, tatsächlich gibt es ja keinen Prozessor, der so heißt, sondern G3 ist eigentlich so ein Marketing-Term für den PowerPC 750 und die da noch kommen, 740, also die dritte Generation von PowerPC-Prozessoren. Die erste war halt 601, dann kamen 603, 604 und jetzt sind wir sozusagen beim 750er angelangt. Und tatsächlich ist der 750er eine konsequente Weiterentwicklung des 603-Prozessors. Das schlägt sich darin nieder, dass das Ding also wirklich sehr viel schneller ist, was Integer-Geschichten betrifft, also die Benchmarks zumindest sind durchaus begrüßenswert hoch. Real-World-Performance kann ich jetzt nichts zu sagen. Wo sie nicht ganz so viel zulegen, das ist der Fließkommabereich. Das heißt, wenn es im Wesentlichen um Floating-Point geht, also irgendwie 3D-Programme oder Grafik, die viel Floating-Point benutzen... Das ist im Wesentlichen Integer, es sei denn du arbeitest mit komplexen Filtern. Da würde es meiner Meinung nach auf einen konkreten Test mit der Software, die du einsetzst, hinauslaufen. Wenn du dahingehend planst, sehr weitarbeit zu sein oder sogar ein Multiprozessor-System dir in Zukunft zu installieren, um darauf BIOS oder Rhapsody drauf zu fahren, dann ist eine 604-Maschine eigentlich der bessere Tipp, weil die sind bei Floating-Point sehr robust und da kann man eben bei diesen 7500, 600 Computern und so eine Einsteckkarte, wo du einfach einen Prozessor austauschen kannst und auch G3 reinstecken kannst. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwie noch einen 7600 oder so was schießt, bist du besser mit Bedienst, weil dann kannst du ja später für einen nützigen Preis deine G3-Karte reinstecken.
Ach so, das geht bei den G3 nicht, dass ich dort die Prozessorkarte auswechsel.
Das hängt jetzt mehr von den Systemen ab. Die neuen Geräte, die Apple vorgestellt hat, die sind nicht mal so, ich weiß nicht genau, wie das mit der Erweiterbarkeit mit den Prozessoren da ist, aber nicht so easy wie bei den 604-Rechnern.
Dann könnt ihr ja auch mal ein bisschen was zur Geschichte der Prozessoren von Apple erzählen. Ihr habt ja bis jetzt immer nur die Innenseite so stark beleuchtet.
Die Prozessoren von Apple sind ja im Wesentlichen die Prozessoren der Firma Motorola. Das ist der andere große Competitor. Du hast jetzt keine konkrete Frage zum Prozessoren?
Nee, nee, das heißt nur ein allgemeiner Hinweis.
Ja, okay, dann nehmen wir das doch einfach mal auf. Bis dann.
Zum Namen Motorola fällt mir noch was ein. Und zwar hat die Firma Motorola angefangen, Autoradios zu bauen. Und Motorola, das kommt so aus dieser Pianola und was es sonst noch so an Instrumenten gibt, Historia. Das war also deren Brand für Autoradios, kommt der Name. Motorola.
Und dann haben sie angefangen, Prozessoren zu bauen.
Genau, irgendwann. Und waren damit deutlich erfolgreicher als mit Autoradios.
Genau, also Motorola hat, ich glaube, wirklich richtig angefangen mit den 6800er-Familien. Ist das richtig? Das war, glaube ich, so deren erste Serie. Das war so zu Zeiten von 650 02 und Z80, Ende 70er, Anfang 80er Jahre. 6809 war so eine etwas populäre Variante von dieser 6800er-Familie. Und ich weiß nicht, wo steckt denn dieser 6809 drin?
Der 6809 war in einem französischen Heimcomputer drin, der hieß TO5. Und der 6809 war insbesondere deswegen sehr erfolgreich, weil es einen Ausgezeichner auf diesen Prozessor abgestimmtes Betriebssystem gab. Es war ein 16-Bit internen Prozessor, also sowas wie die Z80. Du konntest mit 16-Bit-Values komfortabel handeln nach außen. Das war ein 8-Bit-Prozessor, aber es gab ein klasse Betriebssystem für dieses Ding. Motorola hat sich dann im Wesentlichen auf die 16-Bit-32-Bit-Reihe 68.000 konzentriert.
Mit denen sie auch sehr erfolgreich waren, die steckten dann in den Macs natürlich drin, Amiga, Atari, vielen frühen Unix-Rechnern, die alten Suns waren glaube ich alle 68.000 rechner.
Sun 2, Sun 3, Entschuldigung. Richtig, 68.000.
Ja, und eben auch im Macintosh, ich weiß nicht. Die Lisa hatte die Lisa auch schon in Motorola, da bin ich mir gar nicht so sicher.
Die Lisa war auch 68.000, aber die war so vom Systemmodell und auch vom geplanten Betriebssystem ganz anders als der Mac, aber der Mac hat sich dann durchgesetzt.
Ja klar, die Lisa war die, na gut, okay. Jedenfalls da ging es dann los.
Ja, und 68.000 lebt auch noch so richtig, also irgendwie der Pilot, der kleine Palm Pilot, der jetzt so populär ist, den sich viele Leute kaufen, der hat auch ein 68.000er Prozessor, aber so ein Embedded-System, wo nicht nur die CPU drauf ist, sondern eben auch noch, was man sonst eigentlich in einem Computer noch so braucht, wie serielle Schnittstelle und so, das hatten wir ja schon.
Das ist richtig cool, man kann da direkt das Display anschließen, kein Grafikkontroller.
Naja, vor allem die 68.000 zeichnet sich durch eine ausgezeichnete Assembler-Programmierbarkeit aus. Das ist halt eine Maschine, die dafür designen wurde, von Menschen programmiert zu werden im Gegensatz zu den RISC-CPUs, die dafür designed sind, von Compilern programmiert zu werden.
Oder die Intel-CPUs, die überhaupt nicht designen sind.
Einfach nur gewachsen. Christoph ist 14 Jahre und ist gerade am Telefon.
Ich habe eine Frage zu diesem RAM. Du hast gesagt, der PC wird zu langsam, wenn man zu viele Arbeitsspeicher aufrüstet. Warum eigentlich?
Das haben wir nicht gesagt, aber das stimmt.
Warum eigentlich?
Das erklärt sich wie folgt. Wir haben vorhin von dem Cache-Rang geredet. Das ist dieser kleine Zwischenspeicher, der aber ausreicht, die meisten Programme schneller ablaufen zu lassen. Dieser Cache-Speicher muss sich mit dem echten Hauptspeicher, der sehr viel größer ist, koordinieren. Das heißt, wenn da Platz gebraucht wird, dann müssen die Daten, die in dem Cache drin stehen, wieder in den eigentlichen Hauptspeicher geschrieben werden. Um das zu tun, muss man da spezielles Sonder-RAM in dem System unterbringen, was dafür zuständig ist, sich die Adressen zu merken.
Das sogenannte Tag-RAM.
Das sogenannte Tag-RAM. Dieses Tag-RAM ist halt auch eine bestimmte Größe. Je nachdem, wie groß das ist, dadurch bestimmt sich, wie viel tatsächlicher Hauptspeicher durch diesen Cache adressiert werden kann. Wenn dieses Tag-RAM zu klein dimensioniert ist, dann kann nur eine gewisse Menge Hauptspeicher bei gängigen Prozessoren heutzutage, zum Beispiel 64 MB Hauptspeicher oder 512 MB Hauptspeicher, maximal adressiert werden. Und alles, was du darüber hinaus in den Rechner reinsteckst, wird direkt adressiert. Das heißt, ohne den Cache und macht die CPU erheblich langsamer.
Und wer weiß ich denn, wenn ich mir jetzt ein Speicher kaufe, es soll ja auch gehen, dass man höher aufrüsten kann. Ich weiß nicht, ob das zum Geht oder nicht.
Du redest doch jetzt von diesem Pentium-Bug, oder?
Nein, das ist ein Board-Designer-Bug, vielleicht auch eine Sparmaßnahme. Die haben an diesem Techramm gespart, sodass du höchstens auf 64 MB aufrüsten kannst, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass du mit diesem Board sowieso nie mehr als 64 MB benutzen wirst.
Also in der Prinzipkeit ist es so, dass es... Moment, Moment, halt.
Das ist noch was anderes.
Das ist im Prinzip vom Chipsatz im Moment wesentlich bestimmt. Es gibt verschiedene Chipsätze, um solche Cache-Memory-Designs zu realisieren, also solche Systeme zu realisieren. Da gibt es die Weltfirma Intel, die z.B. VX und HX herstellt. Und je nachdem, welcher Chipsatz da drin sitzt, in dem System, dadurch wird eben auch die Casual Area Size, also die Größe dieses cachebaren Bereich, bestimmt.
Das sollte aber auch im Manual zum Mainboard stehen.
Genau, und dann gibt es eine bekannte Computerzeitschrift, die einen Testprogramm entwickelt hat, mit dem man prüfen kann bei den Dosen, wie das dann aussieht mit dem System. Wir wollen diese Zeitung jetzt nicht nochmal nennen. Viel Spaß.
Jetzt aber nochmal die Sache mit dem Pentium 2.
Na, beim Pentium 2 haben sie einfach Adressleitung gespart. Der kann halt bloß 512 MB adressieren.
Und wenn du halt mehr reinsteckst in deinen großen Computer, dann ist halt braun.
Nee, kannst du halt einfach nicht.
Doch, du kannst sie reinstecken, aber da wird die Kiste so schnell wie ein Pentium.
Nein, du kannst sie nicht reinstecken. Also du kannst sie reinstecken, aber er zeigt sie dir gar nicht erst an.
Und wie hat dann bitte schön die Computerzeitschrift da die Benchmarks drauf verankert bei den Kisten?
Du hast mich unrecht, das Problem ist, dass das Tag RAM innerhalb der CPU nur 512 MB RAM ist. Oh Gott, ich war gar nicht da.
Das interne Cache kann nämlich nicht mehr als 512 MB RAM interessieren. Du kannst natürlich mehr reinstecken in deinen Computer, aber danach ist es halt braun.
Also Pentium 2 ist eben auch problematisch, wenn man plant, mehr als ein halbes Gigabyte Hauptspeicher in seinen Rechner reinzustecken, was aber inzwischen nicht mehr so völlig abwegig ist. Also es gibt heutzutage vergleichsweise viele Computer, die auch einen Gigabyte Hauptspeicher gerne haben.
Ja, mir fällt da auch gleich einer ein.
Mir fällt eine Frage auf, die im Chatkabel gestellt wird. Wenn ich euch dazu höre, muss man eigentlich auch noch von Computern haben, wenn man Mitglied im Chaos Computer Club werden möchte?
Also das mache ich auch ernst, weil die Mitglieder des Chaos Computer Club kann nicht für alle sprechen, manchmal haben die alle Kennen, sind ja über das ganze Bundesgebiet verteilt. Sind halt Leute, die sich, wie soll ich sagen, für den kreativen Umgang mit Technologie interessieren. Das ist ja das, worum es uns geht. Hacken ist kreative Beschäftigung mit der Technik, die uns heute überall umgibt. Und die Auseinandersetzung damit, die kann sehr vielfältig sein. Also man kann sich eben in diese Computergeschichte reinstürzen. Heute übertreiben wir es halt mal wieder in der Radiosendung, weil das einfach mal wieder an der Zeit war, das was übertreiben nach den lustigen Sendungen der letzten Zeit. Aber es gibt auch sehr viel sonst wie Freigeister, die sich sehr viel mehr vom politischen Ansatz einsetzen, gerade in der Öffentlichkeit. Es gibt Leute, Phone-Freaks, die eine ganz eigene Art und Weise haben, mit Technologie umzugehen, die nicht unbedingt Programmierer sind, die aber sich durch jedes Telefonnetz auf diesem Planeten in Windeseile durchhacken können.
Also es gibt zum Beispiel auch die Fraktion, die sich damit beschäftigt, Schlösser gewaltfrei zu öffnen, was auch aus dem Kreis des Clubs entstanden ist.
Blockpicking.
Aber ich meine, bei der heutigen Diskussion würde es schon Sinn machen, wenn man sich für Computer interessiert, wenn man teilnehmen möchte.
Nichtsdestotrotz bedanke ich Nis für die Überantwortung.
Alles klar, kann man ja mal wieder ein bisschen gute Musik hören.
Die neuen Worten hacken um, ist schön. Trotzdem ist Uwe am Telefon. Hallo Uwe.
Hallo, ich bin nicht so ein Profi. Ich hab das eben verfolgt hier mit dem Arbeitsspeicher, mit den RAMs. Dann ist es also ein Gerücht, dass Windows 95 dann nur eine bestimmte Megabyte Anzahl verwalten kann. Oder das hat mir einer erzählt, oder ist das wahr?
Also jeder Computer hat irgendwo eine Beschränkung. Die Frage ist, ob ihr jetzt von dem Betriebssystem oder vom Prozessor ausgeht.
Also jeder, der seinen Computer ausreichend mag, um da mehr als 64 MB reinzustecken, hat garantiert kein Windows 95 drauf.
Naja, in dem Moment halten beides eigentlich alle an den Punkt vorbei.
Also es ist tatsächlich so, dass Windows 95 damit keine Probleme haben dürfte, weil es ist 32-Bit-fähig und die kümmern sich darum einfach nicht. Also das, nachdem die 16-Bit... Also gut, ich möchte das nicht beschwören, weil ich den Source nicht kenne, aber ich glaube, dass man da eher durch die Maschine behindert wird, als durch das Betriebssystem. Also in diesem Zusammenhang, in vielen anderen natürlich.
Nö, weil mir jemand erzählt hatte, dass das Betriebssystem nicht mehr verwalten kann.
Naja, es gibt früher bei Betriebssystemen so Adressraumhalbierungen, dass man irgendwie das oberste Bit dafür genommen hat, irgendwie anzusagen, dass es sich um System- oder User-Adress-Space handelt und dann selbst wenn so eine Einschränkung bei Windows 95 wäre, dann hätten wir immer noch einen Gigabyte Adressraum.
Naja, aber einen Gigabyte, ich meine, wir kennen Maschinen mit einem Gigabyte RAM, ich kenne vor allen Dingen viele Maschinen.
Ich fahre nicht Windows 95, und das ist eine gute Idee.
Das war aus gutem Grunde verlegt, Windows 95.
Also es ist bei PC vor allem so, dass die Computer selbst, und zwar die einzelnen PC-Geräte, teilweise Fehler aufgewiesen haben, die verhindert haben, dass das Betriebssystem mehr RAM überhaupt ansprechen kann, beziehungsweise du kannst halt mehr reinstecken, aber irgendwie da wird halt nicht erkannt, weil das BIOS-braun ist, weil vielleicht auch bei Windows 95 ein Bug drin ist. So grundsätzlich, für den Heimbereich reicht das derzeit irgendwie, was Windows 95 ansprechen kann. Bei größeren Computern reicht das halt nicht aus. Der Trend geht eben jetzt auch schon, also nicht jetzt unbedingt im Konsumermarkt, aber der technologische Trend geht jetzt ganz klar auf die 64-Bit-Prozessoren zu, weil es auch in der Software-Technologie eine Menge Gründe dafür gibt, mit 64-Bit zu arbeiten und nicht nur mit 32-Bit, also Programmierer empfinden das eher als eine Beschränkung mit den 32-Bit, auch wenn es gegenüber 16-Bit viele Probleme gelöst hat. Und mit 64-Bit kommt man dann wahrscheinlich eine ganze Weile lang aus.
Naja, das ist aber ein Irrglaube.
Haben wir den Anrufer eigentlich noch in der Leitung?
Ja, nein. Weil Speicher natürlich auch alles billig geworden ist. In der Amiga meine ersten 4 Megabyte, die haben noch 300 Mark gekostet, da kriegt man heute auch nicht viel für. Und mit dem PC machen wir inzwischen so grafische Sachen, dann dauert es ja dann doch immer. Wenn man wenig Arbeitsspeicher hat, nicht beim Bearbeiten dauert es ja dann doch. Und wenn es so billig ist, kauft man sich da mehr und geht dann schneller.
Man muss im Moment wirklich aufpassen, wenn man solche Sachen machen will, dass man sich ein System aussucht, was auch tatsächlich in der Lage ist, so viele Hauptspeicher zu verwalten.
Das war aber auch schon immer so.
Ja, aber das mit dem PC ist wirklich haarig im Moment.
Wird es auch noch eine Weile bleiben. Okay, Frage 41.
Alles klar.
Irak-Konflikt. US-Außenministerin Albright will in der Nacht nach Europa fliegen, um in Paris, Moskau und London für eine harte Linie zu werben. Albright droht am Abend erneut mit einem militärischen Schlag gegen den Irak, falls die UNO Waffeninspekteure nicht ungehinderten Zugang zu allen Einrichtungen bekämen. Großbritannien unterstützt den Irak-Kurs Washingtons. Frankreich und Russland setzen dagegen auf eine Verhandlungslösung. Baufelsaffäre. Der unter Korruptionsverdacht stehende Potsdamer Baustadtrat Kaminski muss seinen Posten räumen. Das Stadtparlament stimmte mit zwei Drittel Mehrheit für die Amtsenthebung. Kaminski wird Vorteilsnahme im Amt vorgeworfen. EU-Strafe. Der VW-Konzern muss wegen unzulässiger Verkaufspraktiken seine Geldbuße von über 200 Millionen Mark bezahlen. VW will die Geldstrafe nicht akzeptieren und kündigte eine Klage beim Europäischen Gerichtshof an. Nordirland-Konflikt. Ohne Ergebnisse ist gestern in London eine weitere Verhandlungsrunde über die Zukunft Nordirlands beendet worden. Kernpunkt der Gespräche ist eine britisch-irische Friedensinitiative.
Sport.
Skifahren. Martina Ertle hat am Abend den Riesen-Stadion im schwedischen Aare gewonnen. Zweite wurde die Schweizerin Sonja Neff, dritte die Schwedin Anna Ottorsson. Fußball. Rund fünf Monate vor Beginn der Weltmeisterschaft hat die französische Nationalmannschaft gegen Spanien mit 1 zu 0 gewonnen. Das Testspiel war der Höhepunkt der Eröffnungsfeier des neuen WM Stadions statt Stade de France. Nachts aufgelockerte Bewölkung minus fünf bis minus zehn Grad. Achtung, Glätte durch überfrierende Nässe. Am Tage Niederschlags frei minus ein bis drei Grad. Verkehr. Brandenburg A24. Von Dreieck Dosse bis Dreieck Hafenland ist ein Schwernaztransport unterwegs, der nicht überholt werden kann. Vorsicht bei der Annäherung. Brandenburg Frankfurt Oder. In den Landkreisen Oder, Spree, Märkisch Oder, Land und Stadtkreis Frankfurt Oder. Sichtweiten unter 50 Meter. Kraftfahrer werden gebeten, ihre Fahrweise der Witterung anzupassen. Brandenburg Potsdam im gesamten Bereich. Glättebildung durch überfrierende Nässe, insbesondere auf Rundesautobahnen und Bundesstraßen. Stellenweise Sichtweiten unter 50 Meter. Bitte fahrt vorsichtig.
Das war Kassin Koch mit dem Fritz Kurzinfo.
Und natürlich von Geekz.
Ich bin schon mal da.
34 dann auch noch mal verdoppeln.
Also jetzt momentan ist es mit schneller. Erst mal wissen wir, haben wir diskutiert, so Gigahertz, das ist jetzt in Aussicht und jetzt...
Achso, da wird noch gefragt worden mit den Gigahertz-Prozessoren, ne?
Naja, und jetzt...
Die kommen noch...
.kommt nicht nur schneller, sondern breiter.
Dieses Jahr tausender.
Weil das hatten wir ja gerade 64-Bit.
Genau, aber jetzt wird alles besser. Genau. Mit 64-Bit wird alles gut.
Vor zwei Jahren...
Glaub sie.
Vor zwei Jahren können wir uns bestimmt, die meisten können sich bestimmt erinnern, gab es tolle Werbekampagnen von der Feldfirma IBM, die damit warb, dass ihr aktuelles Betriebssystem 32-Bit-Showen hätte.
Ja, genau. Windows 95 kann alles wegen der 32-Bit. Wenn ich 32-Bit drin habe, kann ich auch alles. Er hat nicht viel gebracht. Das Problem ist, dass es da mal wieder sehr viel Missverständnisse gibt. Leute glauben, ihre Buchhaltung würde irgendwie bessere Bilanzen abliefern. Wenn sie halt 32-Bit sind, ich nicht. Aber es gibt Leute, die das glauben. Was daran liegt, dass alles angeblich besser sein soll, dass es mehr Bit hat. Ich erinnere an die Diskussion, die bei Spielekonsolen immer so geführt wird. Nintendo 64 ist besser, weil 64-Bit und PlayStation ist nur 32-Bit, dass es für die PlayStation aber viel mehr Programme gibt. Das wird dabei komplett weggelassen und es ist ja nicht so, dass man nicht auch mit 32-Bit ein schönes Spiel programmieren könnte.
Wobei, ich meine, das mit dem Bit, das ist halt auch immer so eine Geschichte, das sagt zwar zunächst mal wenig aus und das klingt eigentlich auch nicht sehr sinnvoll, bloß durch die bloße Verdopplung irgendeiner Zahl jetzt einen bahnbrechenden Fortschritt zu erreichen, weil es auch immer eine Verdopplung ist. Man gewöhnt sich dann an die Größe der Zahlen, es ist irgendwie gar nicht mehr einsichtig, was jetzt die Dimension ist. Aber Tatsache ist halt, dass diese Bitbreite der Prozessoren auch die Generationen der jeweiligen Prozessoren mit angibt.
Ich sollte mal sagen, was da eigentlich so breit ist. Also es gibt ja nur verschiedene Dinge, die so breit sein können. Das eine sind die internen Register, also wie große Zahlen der Prozessor intern selber mit einem Schritt handeln kann. Dann gibt es die Busbreiten, also wie viele Bits gleichzeitig dieser Prozessor an das System zum Beispiel in den Speicher schicken kann. Dasselbe gilt dann auch noch mal für diese Erweiterung Slots, also auch so ein PCIe, 32 oder 64 Bit haben.
Das gilt für die Adressleitung der Prozessor.
Das ist der Punkt, glaube ich, um den es geht.
Also der eigentliche Vorteil bei mehr Bit gegenüber weniger, also war deutlich sichtbar bei 32 gegenüber 16. Man konnte endlich den gesamten Speicher mit einer Adresse adressieren. Man musste nicht mehr mit komischen Offsets hantieren. Und man konnte seine Files von vorne bis hinten ansprechen mit 32 Bit. Heutzutage, wo es 9 Gigabyte Platten gibt und noch deutlich größere, ist es natürlich anders geworden. Und es ist immer von Vorteil, wenn man alles direkt ansprechen kann. Man kann zum Beispiel ein File in den Adressraum legen, also nicht sequenziell draufzugreifen, sondern es einen bestimmten Adressbereich mappen. Und wenn man nur 32 Bit hat, aber ein 4 Gigabyte großes File oder größer geht es halt nicht mehr. Und heutzutage sind wir halt schon so weit, dass uns die 32 Bit Adressraum nicht mehr ausreichen.
Ja, schon für durchschnittliche Bildverarbeitungsanwendungen möchte man eigentlich schon fast mehr als zwei.
Genau, Ampere, Kompression, Dekompression.
Und du hast vorhin das Arbeit mit großen Dateien, das ist glaube ich auch der treibende Faktor. Und auch für die Softwareentwicklung noch mal einen Schritt nach vorne. Hatten das ja vorhin schon, dass irgendwie dieser Schritt auf 32 Bit und vor allem auf Virtual Memory, also die MMU-Geschichte, was für die Software gebracht hat. Weil das Schreiben von Programmen einfacher geworden ist. Man musste sich nicht mehr so sehr viele Gedanken darüber machen, wie viel Speicher man denn nun hat und wo man was abgelegt hat. Man wurstelt einfach in einem irgendwie virtuell großen Speicherraum, der eben maximal 32 Bit groß ist. Das war halt relativ viel, dachte man. Und der Prozessor kümmert sich dann halt darum, tatsächlich das dann auch in bestimmten physikalischen Speicherbereichen zuzuordnen. Und in 64 Bit wird dann noch mal eine ganz neue Dimension erschlossen. Man kann sich ja mal hinsetzen und mal die Zahlen miteinander multiplizieren. So 2 hoch 16, 2 hoch 32 und 2 hoch 64. Das ist die Zahl, die wir dann nicht mehr auswendig wissen. Typische Computerfree kann ja zumindest die Zweierpotenzen bis 65.536 auswendig runterbeten. Und jetzt kommen wir auf 64 Bitten. Das wirft natürlich auch wieder eine interessante Frage aus. Was wird also diesmal passieren?
Also ich meine zunächst mal gibt es eine ganze Masse schmutzige Jobs. Weil das Problem bei diesen Adressraum Verdopplung immer ist, dass es ganz viele C-Programme gibt. Und C-Programme zeichnen sich dadurch aus, dass man halt sehr eng auf dieser Maschine arbeitet. Und üblicherweise also mit einer Verdopplung, der Adressbreite jede Menge Mist am Hals hat. Und bei der Umstellung von 16 auf 32 Bitt kann ich mich an viele Probleme, die diskutiert wurden, mit dieser Umstellung erinnern und dann viel Software, die angefasst werden musste, die hässlich war. Und genau den gleichen Spaß, den haben wir jetzt auch schon wieder nach kurzer Zeit.
Ja, vielleicht können wir uns mal die Player auf dem 64-Bit-Markt angucken. Im Wesentlichen durch einige Entwicklungen sind ein paar rausgefallen. Zum Beispiel Spark wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt. Die haben zwar schon mit dem Ultra-Spark eine 64-Bit-Architektur, haben sich jetzt aber zu Merced committed. Merced ist der 64-Bit-Chip, den Intel entwickelt. In Zusammenarbeit mit HP, denn HP hat auch seine Prozessor-Linie aufgegeben. Um noch kurz die anderen zu nennen, die noch im Rennen sind, da hätten wir MIPS bei SGI, die jetzt mit dem R12000 schon eine Weile eine 64-Bit-CPU haben. Jetzt die neueste ist die R12000 und dann gibt es natürlich die neuesten PowerPC-CPUs, die auch teilweise 64-Bit können. Der neueste, der vorgestellt wurde, ist der Power 3 von IBM. Und dann, meiner Meinung nach interessantesten, haben wir Digital mit dem Alpha-Prozessor, der 21.2.64, die neueste Generation, ist jetzt das neueste aktuelle Modell. Alpha hat den Vorteil, dass sie schon sehr viel Erfahrung haben mit 64-Bit, weil die das schon seit Jahren machen. Der Alpha ist schon immer 64-Bit gewesen. Und vielleicht noch mal ein paar Zahlen zur Performance zu nennen. Diese Chips liegen alle so im 500 MHz Bereich und aufwärts. Das heißt, der neueste Alpha mit 633 MHz wird da kommen. Und bei den anderen wird es nicht anders aussehen. Die Speicherbandbreiten sind stark gewachsen. Die Prozessoren liegen bei 4 bis 6 Gigabyte pro Sekunde Speicherbandbreite. Das heißt, diese Prozessoren können in einer Sekunde so viel Speicher anfassen, wie eine 32-Bit-CPU überhaupt adressieren kann. Und das Interessante ist, dass Alpha als einzige, die CPU schon fertig haben. Die anderen liegen noch ein bisschen hinterher.
Das liegt sicherlich auch mit daran, dass bei Alpha zunächst mal eine Architektur gemacht wurde und dann wurden Implementationen auf diese Architektur gemacht und nicht umgekehrt zuerst Implementationen gemacht wurde.
Was diese modernen CPUs alle haben, sind als erstes Pipelining. Pipelining bedeutet, dass die Instruktionen in verschiedenen Verarbeitungsstufen angeguckt werden. Sie werden geholt, sie werden decodiert. Es wird ein entsprechendes Instruction Unit geleitet. Die Daten werden aus den Registern geholt, werden wieder zurückgeschrieben und das Ergebnis wird zurückgeschrieben. Pipelining heißt, dass man während man die eine Instruktion decodiert, die nächste schon verarbeitet usw. Dann das nächste wichtige Feature ist Superskalarität, das bedeutet, dass man mehrere Instruction Nuts hat und beim Alpha bis zu 4 Integer Befehle gleichzeitig verarbeiten kann und bis zu 2 Floating Point Befehlen. Meistens gibt es noch Brandschuhe, die davon unabhängig gleichzeitig arbeitet usw. sodass im Schnitt die CPU pro Takt bis zu 8 Befehlen ausfüllen kann.
Klar, wir erzählen euch hier eine ganze Menge würres Zeug, nicht wahr? Aber das tut manchmal ganz gut Not. Wer sich das alles nicht hat alles aufschreiben können oder so und vielleicht auch selber mal ein bisschen hinterher recherchieren möchte, der hat die Möglichkeit, sich bei uns eine Meldingsliste einzutragen, den Chaos Radio Ticker. Wir haben den Web-Server oben chaosradio.ccc.de und dort findet ihr alle Informationen und was ihr dort auch findet, sind Mitschnitte von unseren Sendungen. Dieses Jahr fangen wir jetzt auch an, konsequent die Sendung als mpeg-audio-layer3-Datei zur Verfügung zu stellen und nicht nur in diesem krateligen real audio. Voraussichtlich in zwei verschiedenen Varianten, eine high quality und eine low quality Variante. Und das kann man dann eben auch mit einem richtigen Betriebssystem sich dann anhören. Der Chaos Radio Ticker schickt halt immer Ankündigungen raus zur Sendung und vor allem gibt es dann auch ein Feedback zu den einzelnen Sendungen. Das heißt wir werden URLs sammeln und was jetzt hier vielleicht noch so uns selber eingefallen ist und was noch so gefunden wird. Und das geht dann umhä so in der nächsten Woche raus. Chaosradioticker auf dem Webseite.
Und wenn ihr auch gerne ein neues Video mit uns sehen könnt. Jo, lebe noch. Du bist ja richtig lange ausgehalten.
Sag einfach mal deine drei Sachen, wir notieren uns das und dann beantworten wir das.
Okay, erstens, Spielekonsolen, etc. Wie es da aussieht jetzt, die Entwicklungen, so von damals, sag mal, Atari 800, Z80, C64 Amiga. Ob es nur an dem Betriebssystem lag, dass die untergegangen sind oder ob es jetzt an den direkten Architekturen der Prozessoren lag. Zweite Frage ist, ich hab DEC angesprochen, da geht es mir darum, hab eine Information aus dem Internet, dass die für die Suchmaschinen, für Alta Vista z.B. 4 GB Top-Speicher nur haben und wie die den eigentlich verwalten. Liegt es jetzt an den Prozessoren, dass die das können oder ansonsten? Und die dritte Frage ist mir jetzt gerade wieder mal entfallen.
Fangen wir mal mit den Spielkonsolen an. Also Atari 800, also überhaupt die ganze Atari-Linie basierte auf 65 02. Und auch diese Atari 2600-Spielkonsole war auch so ein Abkömmling im Prinzip davon. Und diese 65er-Serie hat sich auch im Spielkonsolenmarkt lange gehalten. Es gab ja dann bei den Spielkonsolen auch 16-Bit, das war zum Beispiel, ein prominenter Vertreter war Sega Mega Drive mit einem 68000 drin. Nintendo, was hat denn Nintendo drin? Da gab es jedenfalls auch so einen da, das weiß ich nicht. Und inzwischen reden ja auch alle bei den Spielkonsolen von 64-Bit.
Die haben MIPS-CPUs, die modernen Spielkonsole.
Also Nintendo hat MIPS-CPUs.
Und Playstation auch.
Playstation hat auch einen MIPS.
Aha.
Ich meine, die haben, was heißt, durchgesetzt. Die MIPS-CPUs sind ja auch im Grafikbereich immer noch sehr vertreten, so bei Silicon Graphics zum Beispiel.
Stecken wir auch in vielen Waschmaschinen drin.
Ja, also die erfolgen sich doch, für die es ja beliebt hat. Ich meine, MIPS zeichnet sich auch dadurch aus, dass es eben ein relativ cleanes Prozessordesign ist und nicht so eine Wurstel-Architektur, sondern einfach eben stale und schnell und go.
Damals bei den Ataris und so weiter, die hatten ja noch Co-Prozessor-Chips, wenn ich mich nicht ganz hinterhöhre oder so, ne?
Grafikchips, ja.
Grafikchips, Soundchips und so weiter. War das damals vom Prozessordesign direkt so vorgesehen, dass die diese Funktionen ausgelagert haben?
Das ist im Prinzip genauso wie heute. Also bei den Grafikchips waren halt so die Blitterfunktionen drin und also irgendwelche großen Bitmaps über den Bildschirm zu schieben oder ein kleines Breiz zu verwalten, wo du ja nur sagen musst, irgendwie hier ist mein Bitmap und schieb die mal an den Pixel.
Ideal für Spiele.
Aber das sind halt keine CPUs in dem Sinne, dass sie ein eigenes Programm abfahren können, sondern so spezialisierte Chips.
Genau, es sind nicht wirklich Prozessoren gewesen, sondern einfach spezialisierte Chips für bestimmte Anwendungen, im Wesentlichen halt Grafik und Sound.
Das ist ja heute auch noch gängig. Also heutzutage machen das in den, beispielsweise, PCs kenne ich halt relativ gut, da machen das die gängigen Grafikchips, machen eben genau diese Funktionen, dass sie irgendwie blicken können und scrollen können und Pointer verwalten können und solche Geschichten.
Die Soundchips sind immer gewonnen.
Nee, das ist nichts Neues. Ich meine, das ist halt der mehr Systemarchitektur, wie man das verteilt.
Aber bei der Nintendo 64 gibt es im Prinzip auch wieder das Prinzip, da gibt es halt einen Chip. Der Prozessor ist MIPS. Ich weiß nicht mehr, ist der Graphic-Chip damit drauf oder ist er getragen?
Nee, nee, es sind mehrere Chips, aber das kannst du nicht mehr so aus dem Hand halten.
Ich glaube, es sind zwei Chips, aber ich glaube, auf den zweiten ist auch eine MIPS-CWU drauf, die sich um die Grafik kümmert.
Genau, aber das macht die Nintendo 64-Maschine halt so interessant, dass sie halt prima 3D kann, also noch sehr viel besser als die PlayStation. Deswegen sind die Programme darauf auch so beeindruckend, auch wenn es nicht so viele gibt. Also Super Mario und sowas richtig cool.
Und bei den ganzen Prozessor-Designs, die ihr jetzt habt, die Amiga-Betriebssysteme, spielen die da eigentlich eine riesengroße Rolle jetzt, wie die den Prozessor ausnutzen? Gibt es davor Nachteile, sag ich mal, zu MS-Dose etc. im Gegensatz zu Amiga?
Mal als Beispiel bei Power Mac etc.
Ja, also die Betriebssysteme ist natürlich sehr wichtig. Also zum Beispiel beim Power Mac in Torschach hat man heute das Problem, dass der PowerPC eigentlich ein wunderbarer Prozessor ist, aber leider, dass Mac OS irgendwie die Hälfte der Performance schon mal in seinen kleinen Papierkorb, den er da rechts unten immer anzeigt, bezieht. Also Windows NT nutzt es sehr viel besser. Also NT ist ja auch wirklich was völlig anderes als Windows 95, da wollen wir mal nicht drüber reden. Aber Windows NT ist halt schon ein ordentliches Betriebssystem, was so die gängigen Features so bietet, Virtual Memory, Paging und so weiter, Multi-User. Deswegen setzt es sich ja auch auf dem Servermarkt ganz gut durch. Ich will nicht sagen, dass es jetzt das beste System ist, aber es ist auf jeden Fall deutlich besser als Windows 95. Das ist ja von diesem Erfinder von VMS.
Aber das ist im Prinzip ziemlich unabhängig vom Prozessordesign, weil es halt so ein übliches C-Betriebssystem ist, was halt in C geschrieben ist und gut läuft auf Maschinen, wie gut C abarbeiten können, was eben die meisten CPUs heute sind.
Und das Amiga OS ist eigentlich ein sehr schnelles System, weil es eben sehr gut multitasking konnte und von daher eben den Prozessor auch sehr viel besser ausgenutzt hat. Und wie viel ein Betriebssystem ausmacht, das sieht man derzeit ganz gut bei den Power Macs. Wer sich mal dieses BIOS zum Beispiel installiert hat, dieses andere Betriebssystem von der Firma BI, bleibt gesehen. Das kommt demnächst auch für Intel. Die haben es jetzt schon einige Male gezeigt, und da ist Mitte des Jahres, also im Laufe dieses Jahres, damit zu rechnen. Aber gerade auf dem Power Mac sieht man halt wunderbar, was das ausmachen kann. Wenn man mit Mac OS arbeitet, glaubt man vielleicht, einen schnellen Computer zu haben, aber wenn man auf dieselbe Maschine einfach dieses BOS installiert, staunen schon mal zuguckt, wie dieses System in 10 Sekunden bootet und dann auf einmal irgendwie 20, 30 Programme gleichzeitig ruckelfrei ablaufen lässt mit irgendwie Bälle springen durch die Gegend und irgendwie Fraktale werden berechnet. Man kann immer noch überall hinklicken und poppt sofort nach oben. Und dann schaltet man mal zurück auf Mac OS und wundert sich, warum man da immer wieder mal 30 Sekunden warten muss, bevor der Computer überhaupt irgendetwas sagt.
Herr Abluss, dann ist ja die entscheidende Frage eigentlich, inwieweit sind die ganzen Betriebssysteme auf die Prozessoren angepasst?
Das ist wirklich die Frage.
Das spielt aber tatsächlich nur eine Untergrund-Orne in der Rolle, wenn man sich das Mac OS zum Beispiel angepasst...
Das Mac OS ist halt nicht wirklich auf den PowerPC angepasst.
Das ist für eine Maschine programmiert worden.
Das ist für 68.000 entwickelt worden und sie graben da halt immer noch dran. Deswegen haben sie auch diesen Emulator drin und sie schmeißen die K-Komponente nach der anderen raus, um das Ding wieder gängig zu machen. Da haben sie auch durchaus Fortschritte, aber letztlich gehen sie auch den anderen Weg mit dem neuen Betriebssystem, was derzeit noch Repsody heißt, was dann wirklich in der Lage ist, diese Performance auch ausreichend umzusetzen, die da ist.
Heutzutage kann man keine Betriebssysteme mehr schreiben, die sich durchsetzen und die auf irgendeinen bestimmten Prozessor ausgerichtet sind, weil Portabilität einfach eine große Rolle spielt.
Genau. Und bei Java wird sowieso irgendwie diese Sachen mit den Prozessoren weitgehend ausgeklammert, weil Java-Programme mit so einem Bytecode-Engine fahren und ein bisschen verletzen. Okay, vielleicht noch deine andere Frage mit Deck. Gehen wir jetzt noch mal drauf an, die sagen wir schon mal Tschüss, ja? Wie ist denn das bei Altavista?
26 Gigabyte oder sowas, weil sie einen kompletten Index im Rahmen halten, aus Geschwindigkeitsgründen. Und das können sie halt adressieren, weil sie 64-bit-CPUs und ein 64-bit-Betriebssystem haben.
Es ist so, dass bei Altavista eine komplette Dokumentation online abrufbar ist und die ist interessant. Wir haben einen großen Computer, ich denke.
Einen richtig großen, genau.
Das mit den 64-bit-Betriebssystemen wird uns noch ganz schön in Gang halten.
Es gibt übrigens von Linux einen 64-bit-Port auf Alpha, also man muss sich keine allzu großen Gedanken machen.
Und wie ist das mit der Frage, ob das Internet der beste Prozessor sein könnte?
Ja, da braucht es halt durchaus eingehen. Also es gab ja vor einiger Zeit, was und wann ist das gestartet, Distributed-Net.
Es gibt so ein paar Computer, die kann ein Prozessor nicht lösen.
Genau. Also Computer müssen ja ganz schnell sein, aber wenn man in der Lage ist, mehr als einen Computer gleichzeitig an etwas rechnen zu lassen, dann hat das ganz andere Ergebnisse. Vielleicht als Beispiel dieser neue Film Titanic. Die ganzen 3D-Animationen, die da drin sind, die brauchten eine Menge Rechenpower und da kann ein Computer alleine nicht mehr viel bewirken. Da muss man eben viele zusammen schalten und sich Alphamaschinen genommen, auf dem Linux installiert war.
Wie viel hatten sie?
300?
Irgendwas in der Größenordnung, viel auf jeden Fall.
300 Rechner, die gleichzeitig daran rumgerechnet haben. Und dann setzt sich natürlich eine ganz andere Performance frei. Und dieses Verschutern beschäftigt die Technologie ja auch schon lange. Es gab da viele Systeme mit Parallelprozessor, Computern, Transputern, Connection Machines, die also versuchten, mit Parallelität und Gleichzeitigkeit von viel Hardware irgendwie mehr Rechnergebnisse zu erzielen. Aber heutzutage zeichnet sich eher an, dass das Netzwerk, also das Internet, die eigentliche Verbindungsbrücke zwischen den vielen unterschiedlichen Systemen schlagen kann. Und es gibt gute Beispiele dafür. Zum Beispiel dieser Versuch, verschlüsselte Botschaften zu knacken im brute force System. Alle rechnen einfach alle möglichen Kombinationen durch. Das könnte man mit einem Computer eben nicht machen. Aber wenn man das ganze Internet dazunimmt und auf einmal 50-60.000 Rechner gleichzeitig mit ihrer vollen Performance da dran rumknacken, dann sieht das natürlich ganz anders aus. Weil es wäre der PC auf einmal 60.000 Mal so schnell. Und die haben auch einige Ergebnisse erzielen können. Was hatten sie schon geknackt als RC5?
Das vor allem, den Data Encryption Standard.
Genau, erst mal das haben sie geknackt. Und danach haben sie sich irgendwie RC5 vorgenommen. Der wurde vor kurzem auch geknackt.
Mit verschiedenen Bitlängen. Also ich glaube mit 56 Bit Schlüssellänge war das letzte Ergebnis.
Also was ich damit genau genommen habe, dass es im Internet genug Computer gibt, um die gängigen Verschlüsselungsverfahren innerhalb endlicher Zeit zu überwinden.
Sie haben auch bewiesen, dass es überhaupt möglich ist, so ein Softwareproblem auf viele Computer gleichzeitig zu verlagern. Das ist ja nur eine Frage der Intelligenz der Software, die diese Kommunikation löst und dadurch ist dann eben, auch diese Render-Jobs sind ja so ein Beispiel, das gibt es ja schon länger, dass man eben auch so sehr viel mehr Performance rauskitzeln kann. Das ist auch sehr ausfallsicher, so ein System. Plötzlich steht viele Computer zwischendurch auf dem Wall ab, aber im Großen und Ganzen geht es halt voran. Tja, was wollten wir euch damit eigentlich sagen in dieser Sendung?
Das Chaos Computer Club ist auch ein Computer Club.
Genau, wir sind auch ein Computer Club. Und es gibt viel zu lernen mit dieser Welt.
Es gibt viele CPUs und einige sind schlechter als andere.
Genau, es muss nicht immer Pentium sein, aber man sollte immer gut gucken, was man eigentlich machen will. Und es lohnt sich, wenn man sonst nichts zu tun hat, wie Mädchen kennenlernen oder auf viele Partys gehen, sich mit diesen Kramen zu beschäftigen. Weil das ist halt einfach lustig und das macht Spaß. Und wenn ihr auch Spaß an Computer-Basteleinen und an Wissenserhaschungen habt, dann würden wir uns freuen, wenn ihr halt zu unseren Donnerstagstreffs kommt im Club des Kradia ab dem 12. Februar, alle 14 Tage.
In der Marienstraße 11 in Berlin-Mitte.
Genau, alles klar.
Und ansonsten ist es immer eine gute Wahl, im letzten Mittwoch im Monat das Chaosradio zu hören, das ist das erste Mal.
Nächstes Mal gibt es auch wieder ein interessantes Thema, steht schon fest, im Februar geht es um Satellitentechnik. Also wir werden mal so beleuchten, was die Satelliten, die da draußen mit uns herumschweren, alles zu tun, welche Probleme sich da gerade auftun. Was sich da gerade im Digitalfernsehen mag und auch im Internetversorgungs- und Handyversorgungsnetzen, die Satelliten geschützt sind, in diesem Bereich tut. Eine ganze Menge interessante Sachen im Chaosradio, Nummer 25 im Februar.
Hoffentlich wieder zu hören.
Auf Wiederhören. Und Johnny, gute Besserung. Es ist eine Minute nach eins.